[Musique]
m
avenue révélations de tourner en bas
l'émission qui part
avec nous ce soir bernard tapie
ghosn
olivier de kersauson
richert
foresti
owni janot
chic et la france et la lra
gomis
sauf lancerait nouvelle va durer
de plus à fond
la vie
[Musique]
ça va tirer comment ça va l'acquis
bientôt la quille c'est l'avant dernière
émission
mais tout le monde a arrêté et a
remarqué tout le monde ya plus que nous
voilà les jean moulin les résistances
chez nous on ira jusqu'au bout émission
qui s'arrête c'est samedi continue en
fait d'un très très bon concept et si on
faisait l'été avec ça bah oui pourquoi
pas hein qu'est ce que tu fais cet été
ben moi j'aime bien rester mois elle
tempête ont décru de toute façon on est
là jusqu'au 8 juillet la dernière c'est
le 8 juillet voilà
je crois qu'il faudra plus que tous les
tableaux ils sont dans ce décor sont en
vente au profit de l'association
laurette fugain absolument très bonne à
cet accord
et toujours pareil si vous n'avez pas
les ronds pour vous offrir une toile et
bien offrir vos plaquettes
[Musique]
jacques albert attabi
très enfants bernardin juvénile secret
quand même un pote au tour de france qui
est il des trucs
de façon plus que ça secret vais pas
vous le dire un jour je vous le dirai
scinderait des produits un truc ouais et
puis je vous dirai si vous voulez les
mêmes c'est cher bernard tapie va se
recycler dans l'anti âge c'est ça voilà
en tout cas ça marche 75 regarde 75 ans
voilà bernard d'abord merci d'être là
vous n'avez rien devoir ambre et vous
êtes là par solidarité pour tout le
monde en parle parce que c'est l'avant
dernière émission
il ya un an
je sais il a quand même il a quand même
demandé 30 millions l'équipage je
signale que personne ne me les a donnés
sans dans le jardin non mais c'est vrai
franchement ça fait vraiment plaisir
parce que parce que c'est une émission
qui va manquer beaucoup c'est donc je
suis content de venir avec vous deux à
l'occasion d'un de ces derniers en
dévoile à merci alors bien sûr on va
parler politique on va commencer avec
avec le foot avec le mondial avec les
bleus
[Musique]
ici
alors gare à vous expliquer comment
cette métamorphose des bleus dans le
match contre l'espagne il ya plein de
raisons mais on va essayer de sortir les
essentiels la première et la plus
importante c'est le changement total de
psychologie et de motivation quand on
rencontre le togo la corée même la
suisse les français ont beau se dire et
se le dise il faut gagner on va mettre
tout notre coeur me mettre toute notre
énergie ils font appel à ce qu'on
appelle la motivation volontaires celles
qui dépendent sa volonté quand tu
rencontres l'espagne et qu' il s'agit de
passer un cap et surtout de remettre les
pendules à l'heure
là c'est tu fais appel à la motivation
inconsciente celle qui te fait courir le
100 m parce que ton gosse se noie 1 la
vraie différence à s'éclate qui font ils
font appel à des ressources que seule la
volonté ne peut pas de données alors
quand on sait qu'un être humain utilise
à peine la moitié de ses potentialités
car sur un match comme ça tu obtiens des
trucs bon alors ensuite l'espagne eux
ont vécu le contraire on aura mis la
tête comme ça c'est les futurs champions
du monde ce qui fait que malgré
l'ouverture du score aurait pu leur
permettre de temporiser un peu de jouer
les malades restez derrière évasion de
continuer on continue et ils nous ont
donné des boulevards derrière que les
français ont bien su exploiter ses
énormes c'est énorme parce que on a vu
ce que ça a généré chez les gens c'est
inimaginable
c'est une belle démonstration de ce que
les gens sont capables de faire lorsqu
on leur offre un événement qui les rend
humble at war les gens vivraient en tous
les français sans variété incroyable
sais pas si tu as eue dans les rues par
tours 1 c'était une c'est un bonheur
exprimé sans limite et qu'on voit pas
dans autres dans d'autres formes
d'existence ce que le sport et en
particulier le football moi je vois
jamais des gens qui se connaissent pas
dans la rue qui s'embrassent et la
grande salle c'est un quartier où
c'est les boîtes privées oui
alors cette émission est enregistré
exceptionnellement avant france brésil
mais puisqu'on est jeudi soit la voilà
donc tu vas me donner un pronostic
et l'hommage vient de finir c'est
horrible objectivement je ne te juge sa
réputation bernard parce que je ne peux
que te dire glace qui va se passer un
sûrement un et te dire je souhaite
tellement j'ai tellement envie qu'on
gagne que je te fais pas de pronostics
je te fais que mon souhait ouais ouais
j'ai vraiment la trouille j'ai vraiment
peur parce que réellement sur le papier
autant il n'ya pas une autre équipe
franchement il n'ya pas une autre équipe
qui nous est supérieure dit bien sur le
papier sur le papier le brésil nous est
supérieur alors maintenant est ce que
cette espèce de confiance convient de
prendre cette espèce de 2,2 volonté de
ne rien avoir à faire parce que
maintenant ils ont fait l'essentiel on
est en quart de finale contre lundi l'un
celui qui gagnera sera dur à battre le
fait que l'arbitré espagnol
conneries pour nous un difficile
difficile forcément il y avait devant
gérer les espagnols arbitres espagnols
moi je pense que y'aura forcément à dire
sur l'arbitrage un malheureux temps
c'est quoi commentant la merde parce que
c'est le coucher du soleil c'est quoi
l'oiseau derrière julien merle mais
c'est génial honte à la tombée du jour
c'est le panard il fait le maire j'étais
sûr que non
je ne connais pas les saisons la nature
tout ça tu connais pas sa mère la reine
qui emmerde
bon
j'en ai dans mon jardin ici peut déjà de
moreau étaient invités
tous les jours moi je finis la la la la
la
on est devenus potes
vous pensez quoi des condamnations dans
le procès des comptes de l'om bernard
tapie
et je veux qu'on pense la même chose que
quand elle s'adressait à moi
elles ont strictement aucun sens tu peux
pas condamner robert louis dreyfus pour
abus de bien social dans son club dans
lequel il a mis 130 millions d'euros je
dire faut être un peu que 6 de fresnes
tu peut l'accuser de plein de choses
éventuellement d'art fait des contrats
bidons d'avoir arnaqué gelé l'urssaf que
les joueurs et est riche et sur les
impôts je suppose qu'il doit y avoir
dans le dossier des choses mais ils
n'ont pas retenu là dessus donc ça veut
dire qu'il était coupable de rien
d'autre que ça et là c'est du délire on
peut pas reprocher à un mec d'avoir été
puisque le délit d'abus de bien c'est
d'avoir porté tort à son entreprise en
gros en gros un tu porteras ton
entreprise quand tu mets 150 millions
d'euros dans les caisses drôle de
mazaugues donc ça tient pas debout alors
à suite si on veut parler des systèmes
qui tourne autour du foot en france je
parle
tous les clubs ont recours aux mêmes
arnaque qui consiste à pouvoir faire des
salaires concurrentiels avec les
étrangers qui paye moins d'impôts voilà
tout le problème est là quand un joueur
est sur le point de venir en angleterre
en espagne en italie ou en france il
choisit un autre pays que le nôtre parce
qu'il est plus taxé alors puisqu'on
parlait tout à l'heure ça va vous
intéresser on parlait tout à l'heure des
pronostics eh bien je vais vous dire
pourquoi la france est devenue un petit
pays de football l'angleterre tous les
joueurs de l'équipe anglaise joue en
angleterre l'équipe dit à sauve beckham
l'italie tous les joueurs les craintes
aliens journée italie l'espagne tous les
joueurs l'espagne journée espagne les
allemands tous les joueurs allemands
jouent en allemagne les français trois
joueurs français jouent en france
on a rejoint le peloton des pays sous
développés c'est qu'à cause des impôts
ils sont obligés d je pensais pas que ça
c'est globalement ses impôts c'est les
contrôles c'est l'urssaf c'est un pays
qui devient pu tellement pressurisée que
les gens ont envie d'aller ailleurs et
ce qui se passe dans le football ne vous
faites pas d'illusion c'est comme ça
pour les artistes qui peuvent partir
ailleurs c'est comme ça pour tout les
autres sportifs de haut niveau c'est
comme ça pour les grands chercheurs
c'est comme ça pour les grands
ingénieurs et ça va finir par être comme
ça par pour tout le monde que a plus
personne peut être est il y aura six il
y aura ceux qui veulent un attendent des
autres leur salut personnel mais est ce
que cette crise de confiance envers
l'équipe de france finalement ne traduit
pas ne reflète pas une crise de
confiance du pays en lui-même les
français sont très bizarre parce que il
rien sondage sur la croyance le bonheur
et c'est ça qui m'a vachement est à tcc
ça dans le challenge début de l'année
question êtes vous plutôt heureux plutôt
malheureuse 80 2 % des gens plutôt
heureux 80 deuxième question pensez vous
que les français sont plutôt heureux
malheureux ils pensent que 82% des
français sont mal
c'est dément un tournant schizophrénie
total ça veut dire que toutes les
nouvelles toutes les infos qu'ils sont
ce qu'elles sont on va pas reprocher aux
journaux télévisés de dire qu' il ya
tant de morts par le sida qu il ya le
tsunami etc n'empêche que leurs
impressions à eux c'est de vivre au
milieu d'une tempête incroyable rêve qui
fait que tout le monde doit être dans
une merde noire et monde doit souffrir
et pas nous mais c'est pas vrai je veux
dire c'est c'est un des gros problèmes
qui rend ce pays très compliqué à gérer
c'est pour ça que c'est un pays où il ya
un taux de suicide très important c'est
le plus gros consommateurs
d'antidépresseurs au monde la france
très sain ouais c'est vrai qu'au moment
des trente glorieuses on a eu un modèle
social très développé qui était vraiment
bien bien installés qui était basé sur
le partage sur le fait que tout le monde
doit profiter au moins en ce qui
concerne l'éducation la santé la justice
des progrès qui sont faits et puis ils
ont pris pour beaucoup l'habitude d'être
un peu sponsoriser un peu assisté quand
ils se sentent plus dans cette situation
de sécurité beaucoup perdre les pédales
on est aussi un des pays où le divorce
fait le plus de ravages et crée des
situations dramatiques quand un couple
sans moyens divorce cédé il ya des mecs
qui couchent dans la bagnole parce que
ils ont de quoi payer un appartement pas
deux
évidemment heureusement on laisse la
femme dans l'appartement avec les
enfants et le mec il a plein au nord
donc en dehors de la souffrance
affective il ya une souffrance matériel
terrible mais il y avait un sondage dans
le veine observateurs dont on parle d
ici la semaine dernière déjà moi qui me
qui m'étonne complètement ces aides vous
favorable ou non l économie de marché
alors en chine ses 74 % des chinois sont
favorables à la commune marché aux états
unis ses 71 % dans les grands pays
européens c'est 65 66 % et en france et
34% alors est ce que la france est très
en avance et elle a compris que le
capitalisme s'étaient pas bien et lé
post capitaliste au contraire elle est
très en retard il ya un problème non
mais d'abord il est possible qu'il
existe un système beaucoup plus efficace
plus généreux qui rend les gens plus
heureux qu'on le connaît pas un puisque
pour l'instant on a mis en opposition le
marxisme a généré un socialiste plus une
social-démocratie et puis la loi du
marché bon encore une fois la loi du
marché pour les gens c'est l'abandon
d'une certaine sécurité et d'une
certaine protection à peu les gens
commandent un pays le plus protégé
forcément les français sont les plus
opposés à le numéro ensuite ya
l'interprétation qu'on se fait dans le
mot la loi du marché pour beaucoup la
loi du marché c'est la loi de la jungle
et il faut reconnaître que par certains
égards c'est un peu vrai ouais alors
est-ce que le français est plus malin
plus impertinent plus rigoureux pour
exiger davantage c'est un peu tout ça
maintenant il faut que ces français-là
se disent que s'il existe une autre
technique une autre méthode c'est pas la
france qui pourra l'imposé seul parce
qu'elle fait 2 % du monde la fin donc
dans un monde qui est entièrement soumis
à la loi du marché on est obligé de
l'adopter c'est du baratin alors on a
des mecs j'entends besancenot j'entends
tous et c'est bien c'est rafraîchissant
mais entendent dénoncer ils font quoi il
vaut que dal que la france est un peu le
village d'astérix aujourd'hui nombre de
passes et 1 passe et vous avez vu qu'il
a dit les patrons faut tous les virer on
les remplacera ouais par quoi par
d'autres patrons 1 qui auront une
nouvelle hiérarchie toute la société
basée sur une hiérarchie que tu tues tu
mets 150 mecs sur une plage tuer un an
et demi tu reviens il ya un patron il ya
deux adjoints puis elle connard en bas
peut rien vous tous parce qu'il sait pas
quoi faire et la société doit être bien
organisé parce que celui qui est en bas
il a le droit aussi de vivre ne pas être
piétinée d'être protégé qu'on lui pique
pas son dû pour hubert pas sa femme il a
le droit alors c'est là où la société
doit être organisé pour faire face à la
limite aux aux inégalités de la
hiérarchie minière archi elle existe
dans les pays socialistes y avait une
hiérarchie dans les pays capitalistes
une hiérarchie la france est un pays qui
s'accommode mal des hiérarchies pays
assez égalitariste la france ben on lui
a fait sa conception comme ça c'est très
logique en tous les cas tout ça donne
aux prochaines élections présidentielles
une importance considérable un oui
falloir faire attention au programme là
parce qu'après abc moi je pense
franchement qu'on n'est pas dans la
situation dramatique qu'on raconte on
n'est pas bien et là il va falloir être
très prudent je crois que ces actions là
sont les dernières où on a le droit de
se tromper alors vous vous avez pas
revenir en politique pourtant vous êtes
éligibles depuis trois ans mais faisait
parvenir est ce que vous avez peur vous
dit quand je voulais devenir maire de
marseille on a trouvé 100 mille francs
dans un jardin pour m'envoyer en prison
l'affairé om va si je suis candidat à la
présidentielle on va mettre 100 kilos de
cocaïne dans mon coffre 7 passant parce
que bon cop ne tient pas mais quatre qui
l'honorait c'est une manière de dire
qu'on
ne veut pas tout le monde est finalement
bon maison elles ont ils veulent rester
entre eux c'est un métier de faire de la
politique
les professionnels politiques ont
toujours une distance à l'égard de ceux
qui viennent pas de rang mais c'est vrai
de kouchner c'est vrai de borloo c'est
vrai de tapis c'est vrai de tous ceux
qui à un moment donné ont eu envie de
franchir le pas est-ce que c'est
légitime quelque part oui quelque part
louis parce que on n'a pas donné en tout
cas de gages sur la réalité de nos
convictions notre programmation etc par
conséquent on peut croire que on est
capable de séduire sur des éléments
d'appréciation qui justifie pas le vote
c'est pour ça que les électeurs font une
grande distinction entre la côte d'amour
avec des sondages extraordinaire un
kouchner oui le vote 1 le vote c'est une
opinion la côte d'amour c'est une humeur
ça nous ramène d'ailleurs à faire
attention aux sondages alors vous
n'allez pas revenir en politique bernard
mais vous allez intervenir d'abord au
nom des trois millions de gens qui ont
voté pour vous tiens là c'est parce que
du sondage la belle humeur
c'est des bulletins dans les journaux et
puis peut-être aussi au nom du parti
radical de gauche non c'est là que je
suis parti parce que c'est la
philosophie radicale entre parenthèses
qui est peu développée on a l'impression
qu'il n'existe plus de deux mails
radicalisme c'est justement c est faux
souvenirs c'est gambetta c'en est série
c mendès france et l'école publique
obligatoire et l'appel séparation de
l'église et de l'état fasse je veux dire
c'est des choses importantes le dal le
radicalisme qui privilégie l'homme
plutôt que les systèmes qui met l'homme
au centre de ses préoccupations de ces
débats qui considère qu' un état une
nation n'est forte que par l'addition de
ces valeurs individuelles elle reconnaît
donc la valeur individuelle comme un
élément d'appréciation mais à condition
que les intérêts individuels soient
compatibles avec l'intérêt collectif
normale en termes un peu plus simple ça
veut dire quoi chacun se démerde chacun
essaie d'être le meilleur on doit pas
envisager une égalité par le bas rhin
mais face à la scolarité donc à
l'apprentissage face à la santé face à
la justice on doit tous et égaux le
chanceux le malchanceux l'intelligent le
conte tout le monde sait la république
c'est la république c'est la réponse est
ce qu'on appelle la république c'est
simplement alors en 2007 vous croyez
vous à un match sarko ségo
prier pour l'instant il est plus que
probable ouais bien ce congrès que les
mecs comme l'inde comme fabius comme
strauss kahn fait quinze ans les mecs
qui sont là qui rament voudrait qu'ils
vont laisser ségolène royal leur pic
elle non seulement je crois que
connaissent les c1 mais alors là pour le
coup je comprends rien à la stratégie du
parti socialiste rien c'est le contraire
justement de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure du radicalisme l'élection
présidentielle c'est un candidat ou une
candidate qui se présente d'or les
français qui fait une proposition qui
dit voilà la société tel que je
l'imaginé et qui s'entoure des gens pour
la mettre en place le parti socialiste
commence à te dire voilà le programme et
on se met tous d'accord sur un programme
dont on est tous d'accord pour dire la
même chose et après comme un casting
comme un film un film tu fais le
scénario et après tu as le metteur en
scène commence à choisir les acteurs
mais c'est de la folie chaque candidat
socialiste à la candidature devrait
faire son programme
passer devant les militants pour qui les
militants c'est vraiment très sévère la
note est un programme et non pas pour un
homme ou une femme sur un improbable
c'est ça qui les amène d'abord à dire
n'importe quoi t'as vu c'est golem et
toujours à 1000 mm ce qui serait inédit
qu'une phrase avait jamais rien pas
qu'il ya un pas qui pensent pareil au
ray or les sons ségolène royal vendre
son programme celui auquel elle croît 1
si les militants socialistes en vole pas
ils peuvent préférer strauss kahn qui ne
manque pas de qualités qui manquent pas
d'idées ou fabuleuse qui manque pas de
qualités qui manquent pas d'idées et
après par la loi normale de respecter le
vote des militants tout le monde se met
neuf candidats et son programme plutôt
que ça alors ta ségolène qui est pour on
sert un peu la vis le parti socialiste
est là on sert pas la vis ta ségolène
qui est pour le mariage nom déconne pas
les cons se marier tu comprends plus
rien c'est du délire
sigolène vous la connaissez bien oui
elle est sympa près elle parle de blair
mais faut pas vous faire d'illusions
elle est socialiste ah oui oui oui oui
vrai de vrai alors ce qu'aime sabah
allez-y les mecs ex-sarkozy sept copains
mais là non plus non non je laime bien
ouais je le connais on se connaît est
lui aussi cinq candidats redoutable mais
lui il est dans une configuration qui
est plus facile parce que l'ump c'est
devenu son parti il est à la fois
prescripteurs des idées de son parti et
récepteurs de ce que le son parti
propose autrement dit il va nous faire
une programmation qui en main de ce
qu'il ressent et des hommes qui vont le
soutenir pour le faire donc là il est
plus à l'aise pour aller devant les
électeurs que quelqu'un qui va défendre
un programme qui n'est pas le sien donc
je dirais que normalement on a plus de
chance alors c'est peut-être une bonne
ou mauvaise chose chaque français fera
ce qu'il veut mais vous avez plus de
chance de voir sarkozy faire ce qui va
dire qu'il va faire un cahier socialiste
que les socialistes parce que lui il a
cessé son programme et a vu que j'espère
revient dès cette semaine oui j'ai vu
dans la même semaine on a quand même eu
les résidents qui a annoncé qui dira
s'il est candidat au 1er trimestre 2007
mais et jospin qui nous dit
officiellement ce qui l'a pas arrêté
nous dire fou quand même dire que ça
fait un an qu'ils nous dit un autre
témoin ou givet
et si vous m'appelez je vais y aller
donc vous rendez compte on a peut-être
un système à un autre france brésil quoi
limite ça va être de nouveau le combat
des chefs tribaux mais non jospin je
crois qu'il est il se met hors-jeu onze
ans après il se met pas hors jeu en
étant candidat il se met hors jeu en
annonçant qui peut l'être si on va le
chercher parce qu'il aurait pu très bien
ne pas annoncer qu'il était candidat
avant qu'on le demande et là ils avaient
une légitimité quelque part pourquoi
d'abord parce que il croit pas un
instant que ségolène royal est capable
il dit pas qu'elle va pas gagner il
estime tout le monde sait qui la
considère pas capable d'être président
de la république deuxièmement il pense
que les communistes les verts les
extrêmes gauche etc il a à peu près le
seul à pouvoir faire la gauche pure
espèce de la gauche plurielle donc s'il
avait été effectivement demandé 100 qui
dit que
c'était crédible un bon mais là ils leur
demandent qu'on l'appelle alors qu'on le
demande pas je crois qu'il s'est
disqualifiée tu vois que les gens lui en
veulent en plus de cette barre en 2002
qua non ils lui en veulent pas de cette
barre en 2002 il a eu une attitude au
contraire honorable j'allais dire digne
un minimum que tous les politiques
devraient avoir moi le jour où j'ai été
mis hors la politique pour les ans vous
savez je lui suis mis même si maintenant
je suis éligible 1 je considère qu'on
peut pas dire ben tiens je suis fini je
reviens il a été porteur d'un échec
terrible il il en a souffert
terriblement il a eu le seul
comportement digne que tous les hommes
politiques n'auraient pas où aller on
vouloir pense à hasnon il a été au
contraire ils ont plaire alors
maintenant si dit attendez finalement
j'ai peut-être revenir souza devant moi
là ça sent un peu le faisandé quand même
tendance à pied vous serez candidat de
toute façon dont le film de fabien
onteniente et qui s'appelle le candidat
justement j'ai adoré ce mec j'ai
rencontré un il m'a dit qu'est ce tu
prêt page d'une pièce comment s'appelle
le candidat il m'a dit non tu fais un
film avec moi 1 il est vraiment génial
donc on va faire un film ensemble à la
rentrée la whey et j'ai bien aimé son
approche il a il a déjà une bonne idée
alors j'ai déclaré j'ai connu la vie
avec beaucoup d'argent je la connais
maintenant sans je préfère la vie avec
et ben ça vous étonne pas tout est mieux
c'est vachement mieux c'est vachement
mieux parce que les gens essaient de
mettre en opposition
l'argent une bonne heure par exemple
évidemment si tu me dis tu préfères
riches ou en bonne santé ça suppose que
tu es riche et malade oui je préfére est
pauvre en bonne santé il n'était pas
obligé d'être malade parce que tu es
riche un groupe we met donc en bonne
santé richir bonne santé fauvre c'est
mieux en bonne santé risque mais c'est
tout mieux arrêter de déconner la garda
gardant mais vous le ballon mais vous
non mais c'est mieux d'avoir de l'argent
dit ban à voir vous dites maintenant je
connais la vie sans argent ça veut dire
quoi et bien d'avoir un salaire qui
correspond à un salaire de cadre et pas
plus non puisque tout le reste c'est
rigoler
non mais quoi que vous gagnez maintenant
ça ouais et courbis se trouvait qu'il
était trop lourdement condamné hall en
temps ils ont mis deux ans de prison ou
placé pour faire un break puis la
récupérer sur six d'avant on a récupéré
dix huit mois j'ai dû faire des choses
vachement grave quand même pour moi rani
n'apprenant rasant et demi ces
entreprises qu'on donne un type qui
viole dans la rue à
oran que j'essaie donc il a dû faire des
trucs terribles et je crois pas qu'il
ait sénart terrible vous l'avez bien
alors oui j'aime beaucoup
barak a dit on va faire une review
là
bernard vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
tu bien ouais content voir baffie devoir
vous je suis tue bien quand vous
regardez le matin dans la glace vous
dites quoi bernard
le seul moment où je me regarde dans la
glace au moment où je me rase et
franchement je me parle pas dans ce
moment là tapi dans la journée d'accord
dans la journée savary champagnole tout
je me dis allez vas-y mon gars ils
auront par exemple
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit bernard bas comme tout
le monde ça dépend de l'âge à quel âge
pas vers 12 ans là quand on commence à
12 ans
12 ans mel ferrer mel ferrer et parce
qu'ils sautaient audrey hepburn j'étais
fou d'elle et ça se comprend notre
nouvelle histoire d'amour basse et la
scène avec ma femme ça fait 32 dans quel
but
c'est beau 32 ans
est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les gens ont
perdu un peu le sens du couple quoi
c'est la première difficulté ils
divorcent quoi
oui mais il ya des couples c'est
vraiment un coup de bol parce que
tu vois bien il ya des gens pleins de
bonne volonté on va pas se forcer quoi
loin c'est pas quelque chose qui peut
jamais mais peut vouloir la vérité ça il
faut quand même le vous voilà il faut
dire je veux réussir et il ya des
passages difficiles et souvent on
s'aperçoit que situe sûrement que ben
voilà un fils il en y mettant un peu du
sien obtus repas voilà nous on a été
vraiment vachement bien pendant vingt
ans sans aucun problème puis on ait
commencé à rentrer dans l'habitude et la
turne a eu sauf un et sophie nous a
redonné un coup incroyable parce qu'on
s'est retrouvés d'un gros parents avec
les problèmes d'un enfant en bas âge et
c est là tout va bien ah ouais super est
ce que vous seriez prêt à tout quitter
pour leur enterrement sur deux mains
dans la rue vous tombez sur une base s
mais fou d'amour je la mets ma femme
j'ai tout poil avait déjà fait j'ai
arrêté de bosser 1
c'est à dire quand on s'est connus on a
arrêté l'un et l'autre de bosser on a
vécu son lot économies et on a vécu neuf
mois on n'a rien fait d'autre rien
d'autre que manger dormir et tagada
tsoin
2,9 après y ait plus de thunes lille
rennes qu'on bosse quand est-ce que vous
avez pleuré pour la dernière fois à
berlin
quand j'ai vu dans ma loge avait pas les
30000 euros promis
les a mis dans un trou c'est un jeu que
j étais pas j'ai chialé on l'a fait
football mais tu m'en veux pas vous
changez rien quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique ma date de
naissance ouais ouais qu'est ce que vous
pourriez dire de plus négatif sur vous
et tu crois pas qu'il en a été si dit
comme ça sans
moi j'ai été gâté quand on m'a retiré on
m'a privé de mes droits civiques on m'a
privé mais droit parental on m'a
interdit de sport on m'a interdit de
politique comme interdits d'affaires on
m'a dit 'maintenant refais toi
l'authentic ils ont cru que j'allais
d'ailleurs par broc faire jamais
il y avait un moment où vous êtes dit je
vais jamais y arriver à me refaire
après plusieurs fois
et justement si vous deviez était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous changeriez le
sexe ah ouais bah oui j'ai connu mec
maintenant j'aimerais connaître
tu as envie de te rattraper
vous seriez vous soyez un peu et fait
c'est fait c'est pour ça que je te dise
à
qui avez-vous le plus envie d'épater
dans la vie ah c'est un truc que j'ai
jamais aimé ça hein j'ai jamais aimé et
pathé o bernard jeu donner deux exemples
j'avais un beau bateau jamais personne
n'a pu monter dessus voir une photo de
l'intérieur de mon bateau on n'était
jamais ailleurs que loin
il a été acheté par une femme on a vu la
chambre à coucher elle a mangé un ladies
et les le pot de géraniums sur la rn6 à
épater c'est-à-dire non moi je ne sais
pas c'est pas j'aime bien j'aime bien
surprendre j'aime bien être et mais
j'aime bien ça mais j'aime pas épaté
alors deuxième exemple bateau c'était le
premier c'est quoi le deuxième exemple
mon à ma maison d'accord personne n'est
rentré faire des photos dans la maison
qu'il est fier
il n'a pas fait de photos il a piqué les
mêmes
qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous restez
24 heures à vivre à crédit
je crois que je réglerai quelques
comptes quand même quand même mais juste
avant de parler d'avoir il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont pas soldés encore
et encore de 3 bourre pif dans l'air et
ouais il ya 2-3 une tournée à faire
est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé au
suicide
oui une fois en prison non non non
c'était dehors et grâce à la
halle à la présence d'esprit ma femme ça
c'est ça s'est pas fait qu'est ce que la
vie vous a appris d'un tapis qui le pire
n'est jamais certain
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
enterré incinérés un vrai qu'on va
l'enterrer vivant comme en descente le
nom je m'en fous sagement complètement
j'ai pas peur de ça du tout chez voyant
j'ai pas fait trop de mal 1
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit il n'y a
pas tellement de gens qui ont souffert
et donc à la fin du parcours je pense
qu'il me dire allez bien il était temps
que tu arrives
et
deux toiles
c'est pas truqué non je me suis coupé le
doigt avant de venir commenter qu'opel
doit pas j'ai voulu remettre une appli
qui était pas droit qu'elle soit
enceinte un valet plus en prison vous
repasser par la case départ et vous
toucherez sans se reprendre cinq
millions d'euros alors tu en es où
justement et que c'était à faire des 135
millions là aujourd'hui je viens
d'apprendre que
la cour de cassation qui devait se
prononcer en juillet début juillet
le premier président a fait un
communiqué pour dire que c'était
reporter en séance plénière au début
octobre donc ça veut dire que tu as
gagné en première instance et a gagné en
appel la chaire en cassation si en
cassation tu gagnes monte à gagner tu
récupères le pognon et si tu perds serre
jugés entièrement depuis le début non
non c'est là ça repasse devant une
chambre d'appel on appelle on revient à
l'appel ouais mais ça fera là donc je ça
va faire trois mois de plus donc ça fera
12 ans et 6 mois c'est les jours sans
fin c'est sans fin 12 ans et cible dans
la sortie c 135 ans c'est trop dur et
j'ai pas mais tient dans la poche rien
toi ça ira dans les poches de l'état
j'accueille anggun
[Musique]
soir
alors on goût de venir ici ce soir pour
la version collector de votre dernier cd
luminescence vous avait déjà parlé il ya
un an mais moi je vous dis on peut venir
toutes les semaines si vous voulez en
good pas toutes les semaines encore la
semaine prochaine 7 oh oui c'est vrai il
ya encore que la semaine prochaine petit
mystère lui parvenir la semaine
prochaine je l adore cet angle moi vous
savez bien eh bien je suis fou d'amour
ah oui vous le savez plus le ton en
jugeant que je vous le dis je ne sais
pas il paraît qu'il n'y a pas que les
femmes qui changent la vie les hommes
aussi un an ah non moi je change pas
d'avis avec vous
quoique c'est du baratin après que je
suis comme tous les français que je
baratiner tout ça comme tous les
français par les français que je connais
ah bon avant il voudra tiennent pas mais
ils sont cons
bon enfin disons qu'en goût des bons
cadeau de départ donc un
accord c'est comme un pot d'adieu
vers la fin j'ai fait l'internaute à
poil
ou à poils longs
ebr
santé
m
en disant vous n'aviez rien senti
ok c'est moi comment ça va ça va alors
on a beaucoup parlé de la france qui est
morose qu'est ce qui vous plaît le plus
en france anggun la cuisine ici c'est un
art on appelle la gastronomie on ne
mange pas juste pour manger
voilà donc on prend et puis après il ya
le vin
je suis en train d'apprendre à connaître
le goût des vins et voilà connaître la
provenance et cetera il ya plein de
petites choses comme ça qui fait que
finalement la vie chez bouche et vous ne
peut pas être banal que ça je vis à
paris c'est une ville magnifique je sais
pas vous avez un passé littéraire assez
lourd et ça continue pas un mot sur
l'amour et le sexe jusqu'à maintenant
après le vent je pense que
non je commence par par ce qui me touche
d'abord par rapport à leur pays
et puis si tu ne te laissera alors
j'entends que qu'est ce qui vous plaît
le moins en france
les parisiens
mais la raison mais ils sont de mauvaise
humeur bien sûr absolument je suis
d'accord d'accord répond pas le métro ou
les lignes
14 d'accord on y sera voilà à québec à
l'heure mais est ce que vous aimez les
escargots oui vous mangez les escales
régime je mange même les abats est ce
que vous connaissez le début de la
marseillaise
alors
tous les français non non je le fais en
deux jours
ça vous énerve rond-point qui a partout
en france
alors vous savez que il ya cinq ans j'ai
essayé de passer mon permis on commence
par le code ici en france alors qu'on a
donné dit on achète le permis
le ca paris et en france j'en achète la
police à
vous connaître quelle police a va donc
et à l'époque je parlais pas encore très
bien français et on me dit qu'elles ont
commencé par il faut pas chevaucher
pourquoi pas donc on dit qu'est ce que
tu avais dire chevauchée 28 montreux vu
ce que ça veut dire
bon jeu vidéo ouais en fait il paraît
que ça vient du mot cheval oui bien
non
après il ya un mot la rue sens giratoire
je demandais ce que ça vient du bois
girard
regardez le code ou pas alors si aulas
le coup par contre j'ai pas eu le temps
pour faire le père nie donc si un
monsieur de la police
qu'est-ce qui en indonésie qui a pas en
france mais cadbury
et pourtant même là bas stade de france
on a donné à beaucoup c'est tout le
brésil essayer tout le monde a essayé la
maman
rangoon est ici ce soit pour une version
collector donc de luminescence votre
troisième album alors cette édition
spéciale comporte un duo avec diam's un
duo avec david hallyday
des remixes et un inédit
[Musique]
m
touchés
g
et chacun
après
on va voir à quoi ça ressemble j'ai
regardé votre caméra en bonne voie là et
vous dites magnéto richard oui
oui c'est richard ce soir richard
valverde
il vient après sergent il va venir pour
la fin de l'émission rue d'accord quand
vous dites météo richard
magnéto richard sûr
justin
à
je sais pas encore
or
m
[Musique]
je
j'ai vu
et
celle ci un trou pas très sexy anggun
moitié trouve pas sexy ces jeunes très
très sexy elle et elle est là la sq
haute et regard du talent mais elle m'a
fait complètement craquer on a compris
post bisous non mais une poste a suffi
après mais c'était pas bien réussi je me
dis que vous avez rien senti
dacca ans l'album marche très très bien
vous êtes meilleures ventes francophones
dans une quinzaine de pays ça se passe
très bien pour vous oui ça va se plaint
pas c'est gonflé quand même ce que vous
êtes une star en asie vous êtes tout
abandonner pour venir en europe on est
en train de devenir une star en europe
s'est fait deux fois quoi ce sont les
français qui dès qu'il est entré à
narrer ouais bah oui vraiment le tout
recommencer à zéro 1
c'est courageux non sérieux pour ce
bijou
j'ai bien fait les landes récessive ça
s'y prêtait bien à paris effectivement
alors donc tourner jusqu'à fin décembre
et ensuite première partie des concerts
événements de johnny a vidé le flashback
tour c'est difficile quand même se
retrouver devant un public en première
partie qui est pas venu pour vous c'est
terrible si c'est un peu délicat parce
que nous avons toujours cette impression
d'être la seule personne qui n'est pas
invité la soeur aînée mais en même temps
c'est aussi un défi et puis je pense que
le public de johnny est assez comme on
dirait c'est là tout
le génie tout âge j'ai déjà vu plusieurs
plusieurs show de johnny avec les
plusieurs premières parties différentes
et c'est toujours voilà voilà répond
sébastien bah oui ça se passe bien je
trouve que nous sommes c'est un animal à
ya de l'intimidation auxquelles m non
mais vraiment c'est joli comme face à
wayne va lui dire mais on va lui dire
non il ya julio iglesias aussi qui vous
a invité enregistré avec lui une chanson
qui a été écrite par stevie wonder julio
iglesias le chanteur qui se touchent
partez en espagne alors cet été
peut-être je ne sais pas fait attention
à ma cour julio je ne suis pas de rats
gable vous dites justement les
occidentaux amalgame l'hospitalité la
gentillesse des asiatiques ou leur
sourire tout simplement avec la
soumission et ça c'est énervant bah oui
c'est très énervant
c'est comme c'est comme lors de mes
débuts en france quand
j'ai dit je viens d'indonésie ah oui
j'aime beaucoup le massage là bas
et c'est terrible oui une vraie
réducteur csii à massage et massage
c'est qu'on en indonésie c'est vrai ça
fait partie de nos traditions on fait
même des massages aux bébés parce que
c'est un côté tactile il ya un lien
véritables vertus médicales il n'y a pas
de projet
pas dans votre culture qua non mais
c'est vrai que non vous vous dites en
asie la négation et impoli c'est à dire
qu'en france on a été obligés
d'apprendre à dire non quoi dans la
langue il faut peut-être dire il faut il
faut inventer d'autres réponses le trou
on verra bien dans deux semaines il faut
que je réfléchisse on doit jamais dire
non brutalement non c'est un vrai projet
qu'autour de la table
pour pouvoir dire non je me calme et
justement c'est bien
compris le sens giratoire
et la
contribution
elle n'a pas du tout envie d'être
chevauchée
l'apparemment
alors il ya longtemps que vous avez
appris à dire non en règle stricte de
l'islam parce que vous êtes musulmane
vous coup là comme musulmane non mais on
a donné 10 l'islam est très cool c'est
un islam très tolérant ce que d'ailleurs
il faut que le monde entier voir nos
exor notre exemple vous vous êtes plutôt
une musulmane en minijupe ou quoi
mais finalement c'est pas parce qu'on sa
vie comme comme on veut
on ne peut pas juger notre foi que par
notre apparence l'habit ne fait pas le
moine
elle connaît que les esprits qui voient
le 9 valable bravo
c'est parce qu'il apprend que ça mais
c'est organisé doit vous dit le mal
n'est pas dans le corps de la femme dans
la tête des hommes en fait et et le
voile en fait protège les femmes des
pulsions sexuelles des hommes en fait
c'est ça le voile non c'était à la base
très protégé les uns parce que ce sont
nous les sexe fort oui c'est des êtres
inférieurs parce que si c'est sur les
gonzesses d'où l'idée du voile
exactement on le protège
des êtres inférieurs qui ont des
pulsions sexuelles immédiate et pose
bisous
c'est ce qu'on va faire les choux gras
de m'exciter bêtement on va faire une
interview retour au calme
alors est ce que vous mettez des heures
à vous préparer le matin
ça m'arrive ouais est ce que vous
demandez tous les deux jours votre
copain s'il trouve pas que vous avez un
peu grossi et non non
vous passez votre temps lui poser des
questions sur ses ex au début ouais non
c'est pas parce qu'il est normal parce
que si vous êtes normal comme ça d'un
seul coup ça va ça va me calme et
terriblement vous fait la gueule quand
votre maître regarde le foot avec des
potes non il est plutôt et fin
vous l'engueuler votre mac parce qu'ils
n'en font pas une question ménages
mais je fais pas non plus
je mets bien traîner en survêt violé le
dimanche après midi mais j'ai regardé ça
ça c'est dommage vous avez les pieds
froids même en plein été non non je sais
pas frileuse vous acheter plein de
fringues dans ce champ très bien vous le
mettrai jamais non plus passer des
heures au téléphone avec votre copine je
n'ai pas de copine
j'ai fait des copains ils sont tous des
gars comme moi
quand votre mec raccroche ce téléphone
vous demander cette équipe
est formidable et ça va pas s'arrêter
alors si vous êtes aussi extraordinaire
vous coucher que des chaussettes nom des
grands t-shirt obélix
vous fait les poches de votre mec de
temps en temps pour vérifier ce qui est
dedans
pour faire la lessive oui un qui croit
ma fille qu'elle fait là les sens je
crois qu'il fait les poches pour trouver
du fric il est près d'un mois les poches
avant de donner
à la lingère qui fait la lessive c'est
vous qui faites à laisser les blancs
avec les blancs oui le site avec leslie
de toutes les couleurs
vous gueulez quand votre mec regard
d'une autre fille dans la rue et regarde
pas
[Musique]
est ce que vous trouvez johnny depp trop
mignon
mais je la trouvais la vanessa être au
milieu ne sait
donc là ça redescend pas du tout parce
qu'en fait le aucun défaut je me rend
compte
alors compte que des conneries tu crois
luminescence ccb
[Musique]
m
tiens
pardon c'est quoi c'est quoi je sais pas
si je sais quoi et basse non vous devez
vous souvenir et
la terrine tournée de blancs ou de
couleur tirer
en souvenir bon allez c'est mango non
c'est ma peau je ne peux pas parce que
vous n'avez pas
c'est ce que j'aime
[Musique]
j'accueille olivier de kersauson
m
tu es en bonne compagnie anggun la hâte
à 2 tu as deux mettent la main de chaque
côté là nanard et kersaux
juillet mois qui n'a pas vu une femme
et c'est normal il était sur la mer
alors on est très heureux de vous avoir
ce soir olivier pour vous rendre hommage
pour votre double exploit double exploit
le 27 avril dont faisait pulvérisé le
record de la traversée du pacifique
d'est en ouest de san francisco donc aux
usa à yokohama au japon j'ai battu le
record de steve fossett qui était vieux
de dix ans vous l'avait amélioré de cinq
jours premier record donc dans un sens
et dans l'autre sens records le 12 juin
cette partie de yokohama est arrivé à
san francisco a battu le record de bruno
peyron quand je pense que des mecs qui
vous avait enterrés ils ont
de la ressource a ouais ouais non mais
surtout c'est des parcours intéressants
de paco matéo logiquement très pointue
très hasardeuse
des très difficile au retour c'était
épouvantable 1 le temps l'eau on a fait
douze jours de tunnels un jour brume 12
degrés ce 8 et 12 degrés pas de vent et
une mer complètement car c'est un à côté
donc pour jamel journée de glisse jamais
une journée marrant que jamais une
journée la terrible non ça pourrait être
pire et bien ce serait pas battre le
record en tous les cas moi même et là on
était bloqués avec quatre jours d'avancé
petits blocs un anticyclone on pourrait
pas faire le tour la météo du pacifique
c'est en atlantique c'est très simple on
le voit bien et anticyclone des açores
les dépressions centre amérique elle
arrive sur et si l'angleterre ou
l'espagne pacifique il ya toujours 3 4
des pressions et roccat anticyclone et
on sait pas où ils ont la même
dépression avant ce monde dans le nord
repart dans en direction opposée
les prédictions change tous les six
heures mais une nouvelle qu'on a sur la
météo on vous dit qu à telle heure ça va
faire ça six heures plus tard savoie a
condamné un chèvre le parcours était
tordu c'est pas des parcours rapide on
n'a pas été vite en finale j'ai gagné ce
qui était passée avant n'était pas
évident du tout
c'est génial trouve pas quand même
kersauson moi je trouve que je sais pas
quels jeux vous allez mais c'est
incroyable quand même à votre âge il pas
toujours des records trente six ans
c'est pour ça on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble s coupé regarder votre caméra
et dire magnéto richard magnéto richard
merci
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya bien un domaine où la france
remporte deux victoires et se battent à
vue là c'est extraordinaire a plein de
même un la plante un plat on les met pas
assez en valeur ouais aujourd'hui des
records comme ça ça mériterait d'être
connue d'être déçu par tout le monde
parce que c'est pas seulement c'est pas
seulement des sportifs anaky envie de se
surpasser c'est une vraie école la vis
et des exemples a montré tout le monde
ouais c'est quoi votre secret alors pour
gagner
voilà tonna suite et
c'est un sport aussi c'est un sport
qu'on peut faire vieux aussi pas mal
tout ce que j'ai perdu en force physique
j'ai gagné en connaissance de lecture de
la mer moi je comprends ce qui va se
passer et pour en savoir autant que moi
il faut avoir passé autant de temps ah
oui il ya eu il ya des moments où moi je
reçois un bulletin météo chez qu'ils se
sont plantés le sait que c'est là qu'il
faut passer d'eux c'est marrant
s'inspire marrant c'est un sport
faut vraiment être tenace faut être
endurant
faut être sa foi à peu près à mourir
bien sûr c'est de combien sur ce bateau
là on est sept on est sept en permanence
et on prend des étrangers nous sont
australiens ont nommé un japonais ont
aidés
c'est assez marrant il s'appelle
geronimo le bateau parce que le sponsor
il s'y retrouve pas là avance s'appelle
fleury michon herta
saucisson justin bridou avec d'abord
c'est parce que j'ai deux partenaires et
capgemini et schneider electric et en
plus c'est que étant tous les deux au
cac 40 au début ils se savaient pas trop
bien ce qu'ils voulaient monter donné le
nom au bateau et tout donc on a appris
un accord n'a pris le nom de la dinde
hachée fanien respecta très bon qui
circulait pas c'était un peu c'est ce
qu'on leur avait vendu et moi je leur
avais dit quand il m'a quand même à
poser la question s'ils ont aussi on est
partenaire et vous qu'est ce qu'on lui
dit y'a que des risques mais nous on va
tous les risques que dirige maintenant
qu on peut prendre que des coups mais si
vous si vous êtes autre chose que les
lopettes tenez vous venez c'est quand
même un beau métier d'homme l onu ils
ont pas lâchés ils sont contents ce que
tard dans l'année la entre le tour de
l'australie l'un des vieux record qui
sont souvent attaqués comme los angeles
honolulu osaka japon en les retournant
bien cantonné toute l'année mais pour
nous c'est gratifiant
tant que tu fais ça tu es obligé d'aller
aux grosses têtes en plus mieux première
j'ai quand même le grand avantage enfin
la grosse tête j'en dirai pas trop de
mal parce que ça m'a quand même nourrir
pendant des années ouais mais
je suis pas moins me fâche préfère être
mûr ouais si rtl me donner la moitié de
ce qu'ils me donnaient pour pas dire ça
m'arrangerait moment j'ai cru que tu
finirais aux grosses têtes tu vois hélas
tu en train de gagner des records c'est
formidable ce qui se passe non merci
j'ai tout à fait toucher de cette
prévention et c'est de penser que mon
égard
non non non irène la chose de bien plus
dramatique vois simplement c'est
dangereux tu te crois qu'un jour ça peut
moi je suis seul survivant de ma
génération c'est beaucoup plus dangereux
que tous les autres sports tu mets pas
en balance la sécurité et la vitesse
jamais tu choisis toujours l'option qui
va le plus vite ouais ouais mais le
monde a changé le monde météorologique a
changé au fisc depuis 97 dans le la
planète etc
je sais pas si elle serait chose que
quand les mecs te dise qu'elle se
réchauffe j'aimerais voir à quel terme à
mais ils ont mesuré il ya 111 jeunes les
couilles ce qu'on a déjà nous suivait
une cuisson de carbone à degrés près ont
bafoué tu aurais jamais sasserno sujet
mais le les tempes elles sont plus
fortes elecam sont plus longs comme si
l'ensemble des systèmes météorologiques
mondiaux que l'on est dessus tout le
temps avait perdu leur tempérance et les
les attaques de mer qu'on a parfois mais
ça arrive d'un coup ça fait 70 de 140
150 km/heure salève une merde en faire
tout casser c'est brutal le le système
les systèmes météorologiques sont
devenues ou absence de vent ou
apparition du vent avec énormément de
brutalité mais peu de temps mais cassius
clay dix minutes ça abîme
alors olivier vous êtes ici également ce
soir pour un livre qui s'appelle la
bretagne vue de la mer aux éditions du
cherche midi sk vue de la mer se fichant
la bretagne
[Musique]
il faut tard être ce métier mais ils
font tout ce qu'ils peuvent me faire ça
tu vas arrêter prématurément il va te
dire non mais comprendre chambon cas
bretagne la bretagne puisse te faire
chier toi hein mais moi je suis du midi
c'est pour ça non mais même si je
faisais ça demande des qualités
intellectuelles que tu possèdes
peut-être pas exactement
tu es c'était cette avancée de roche
dans la mère de l'un des plus beaux
océans du monde c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait exceptionnel mais que ça
t'intéresse pas mais seul comprend fort
bien je t'en veux pas pour ça donc tu es
parti avec un aquarelliste qui s'appelle
michel bellion vous avez fait du
cabotage artistique enfin les côtes tels
que seuls les marins les voies et
olivier je voulais que nos mères nos
femmes et nos filles puissent partager
notre regard est crucial de la mer j'y
viendrai qu'il vient de dire des propos
délicat sur la bretagne 1
je sais rien tu vois c'est un miracle
mais d'accord
s'impose bisous olivier non non je
t'explique la mer quand tu quand tu
arrives sur une terre la terre c'est
toujours une ombre c'est une ombre qui
ressemble c'est un croquis en fait c'est
jamais une couleur c'est toujours un
dessin c'est toujours ces deux s'est
tout à coup
cet horizon qui est plat il ya une bosse
qui est différente de celle des autres
c'est ça la river cette terre nous vu de
la mer
c'est le code de du monde qui naviguent
la plupart des gens qui payent la mer il
à peine du board dudes est vrai sur deux
sur la terre il paye la mère et moi je
voulais emmener un gars qui fasse comme
dans les chais les navigateurs dans le
temps qu'ils fassent le croquis des
atterrages vers le croquis des approches
que qui regardent la terre vue de la mer
n'ont cessé notre monde ça c'est un
métier très important c'est un métier
séculaire
[Musique]
m
l'indicé phare ne tourne pas ne fait pas
plaisir les gens je t'appelle à
l'oreillette tu ne réponds pas non parce
que tu vas t'occuper mais je suis en
train de discuter c'était déjà en ligne
avec canal+ faut le dire un non mais je
rêve qui on n'a pas fini je te signale
rabat en vacances encore un bon on sait
pas vous vous êtes formidables mais non
ça va pas y ait encore deux émissions à
produire mais on se fait chier la mort
mais là on s'emmerde à c'est tout le
monde son maire dans régime car on
laisse tomber qui c'est qu'a fait ce
plateau là c'est nul c'est tricoche oui
y'a pas assez de fruits sur le plateau
regarde non et oui heureusement qui
embrouille mais
sinon c'est trop
les gens se foutent là bas en huitièmes
ça c'est bien toi tu es bien tu fais du
bateau toujours
du canot et tout ça non mais c'est
intéressant mais tu peux pas raconter
des blagues de cul plutôt comme un peu
comme à la radio parce que la voile les
gens n'aiment pas je crois un laurent
j't'adore texte adore c'est formidable
c'est très bien oui mais tu es un peu
dit qu'est ce que tu vas qu'est ce qui
va faire à la rentrée je ne sais pas
d'où vient alors
le pauvre je sais que des gouttes
en fait ces tabourets qui c'est qu'a
fait ce décor dit tu es payé à l'avenant
tu le fais sans le rôle à vannes et
lisandro tard voilà 3 850 et de sa femme
tout à l'heure il avait une perche là
pour faire une vanne kouyaté lemerle
voilà qui fait oiseaux pourquoi t'as pas
dit au maintien c'est peut-être delanoë
c'est le même de paris ça fait drôle
libertat un
goût là va être très belle injures sinon
ce serait trop chez pourquoi tu demande
pas des questions de fond à bernard oui
pourquoi tu ne demande pas combien il a
payé le togo pour que la france
va donc je vais vous hilarant à quoi non
je suis sur hardy seront
évoqués oui à temps battiston et des
surtapis enfin c'est sur un quart sauzon
ça dépend des moments et puis il ya un
goon entre les deux
mais l'on n'est pas aux chandelles qui
lui conte
mehta du boulot ce top 10 pour la
rentrée internet dont tu te démerdes
l'effet que fait qu'on se bouge là pas
d'accord mais c'est dans les salles
j'ai rarement vu ça c'est très bien
c'est fait c'est pas qu'elle imite
catherine barma c'est l'incarnation de
catherine barma ce qui n'est pas morte
rappelons le
quelques chansons
bretagne bulmer de recherche minutieux
ces succès ghislain qui chanta mais
reconnaît sa carrière au bas mot
alors nous sommes un post bisous alors
dit moi avec tous ses records la télé
sans arrêt absent tout ça on sait pas si
tu sais ce qui se passe en france en
fait a dit que j'ai pas besoin de savoir
en faire une nouvelle mise à jour
est ce que tu sais qui l'entraîneur de
l'équipe de france de foot
domenech bien est ce que tu sais la
sphère clearstream c'est quoi aucune
idée
aucune idée non mais tu vois il sait pas
mais c'est normal il est sans arrêt tu
peux vjesnik itoi clearstream voilà
c'est une affaire très compliquée c'est
une à l'origine c'est une banque qui
lessiveuse quoi elles sont vos
luxembourg qui transforme de l'argent
bizarre en argent en correct
alors les gens qui on raconte là bas en
fait sont des numéros ouais c'est ça
envoie ses cendres et en france à un peu
merdé parce qu'on a mis sur la tête de
certains hommes des comptes qui
n'existait pas il ya certes un autre
homme qu'on voulu faire plonger ces
hommes là en faisant croire qu'ils en
avaient géza c'est exactement ça
donne envie de repartir ouais olivier
ah on va voir si tu au camp qui a été
blanchi de ces condamnations par jacques
chirac
dit guy drut gracié par le président la
république
qui couche avec lara fabian facile ça
guiderait toujours ce normal en avant le
nom de la victime gérard pullicino ça
fabuleux réalisateur de télévision au
pays mais quelle est donc la victime
effectivement qui est harry roselmack
c'est le présentateur noir de tf1
darry cowl mort ou pas mort
mort louis saez
philippe castelli
mort jacques martin
vend très bien bah oui qui a dit la
france aimez là ou quittez la
sarkozy
non mais attends ben ouais c'est non
mais c'est pas pour t'humilier c'est
pour voir si si quand on est à
l'étranger
je sais pas avec quoi sarkozy veut-il
nettoyer la racaille au karcher bien qui
est champion de france de foot
au las olas
non mais c'est normal c'est messi sur
tf1 qu' un jour là
on est quelle année où et lionel josse
pas
chez lui sans vie
keddy la route est droite mais la pente
est raide
unis raffin non mais attends c'est un
des trucs sert à pas que selon mercy si
si si quand je suis parti il est elle
arrêtée là bah oui c'est en tentant moi
j'étais au japon je tiens en parlant à
ses rivales en australie pour ça on fait
ça pour te mettre à jouer mais c'est pas
la peine ça ne m'intéresse pas du tout
ça ne m'intéresse pas de savoir pourquoi
florent pagny va en argentine
quel est le métier
est ce que charles trenet est mort bah
ouais il était mort avant que je parte
alors qu'il est toujours
est ce que tu sais qu alain delon a
promis qu'il ne referait pas de cinéma
non je ne peux pas savoir quels
individus doivent être félicités est ce
que tu sais avec qui la femme de demain
a refait sa vie ah oui assez intéressant
ça
s'entendait et c'est inouï non mais si
un mec qui s'attaque aux histoires de
cul c'est moi tant que je sais pas
afflelou ouais
non
derrière moi d'avoir
détourné de sa vie privée
bien plus tôt qu'on le pacifique à dire
que yang ho de là bas c'est le pays des
anggun 1
que s'est il passé le 12 septembre 2001
j'ai le lendemain du 11
est ce que tu sais pourquoi tout le
monde en parle s'arrête
on sait juste que tu viens me poser
comme question c'est par cas
la beauté
c'est le cherche-midi mesdames messieurs
toi
on est convaincus qu'on fasse attention
c'est quoi
doit faire un bras de fer ils sont en
garde du corps ouais
amène le
attention vous êtes prêts
un
temps de voir la boucherie
1 2 3
et je vais pas lui faire perdre son job
lui si bien résisté
près oui attention
[Musique]
les concours de
hier faisant la bretagne
cette recherche milieu à mes yeux pas
tant
c'est hull et un merci merci d'avoir été
relégué
à la prochaine à la prochaine dans la
mer jaune
j'accueille florence foresti et michel
boujenah
en toute chose
le féliciter
non non c'est extraordinaire le
personnage de ben arma à quel point vous
l'avez choper florence est magnifique
c'est voilà
c'est pire se sent tout à fait peur à
fait peur affreux comme ça va tu connais
kersaux a été excellente alors vous êtes
ici tous les deux ce soir pour annoncer
la troisième édition de rire contre le
racisme
lundi au zénith présenté par ariel
wizman avec smaïn anne roumanoff raphaël
mezrahi rachid à cannes il mouss diouf
cyril hanouna bruno salomone boudeur
magloire cartouches et vous deux
est-ce qu'on peut être raciste et aller
voir le spectacle
oui on lui posera bon ma maman n'a qu'à
bien faire un grand kiff ils vont voir
tous les dimanches avec tes chaussures
les gens de couleur c'est trop la wii
vivant plein d'exemples r si une
personne raciste va voir le spectacle et
trouve ça pas drôle et ressort encore
plus raciste on essaiera les royaumes
sic analystes
dans tous les cas on peut dire merci aux
racistes parce que sans eux il n'y en
avait pas ce spectacle mais ça continue
non c'est vrai
mon frein riches contre autre chose oui
on trouvera toujours contre contre
quiconque baffie conde est actionnaire
et autres boeufs lit
comment ça va florence à la benne bien
bosser un peu c'est bizarre de faire un
sketch et après devenir comme ça en robe
comment t'as pas reconnu certaines qui
est venu tout à leurs habits en
quatrième
j'ai pas de voix mais ça va ouais alors
ya le dvd du spectacle toujours qui est
en vente je crois que faut dire aux gens
de l'acheter bien sûr où sont les gens
les gens sans l'arrière coûte 17 petit
tout petit bisou
merveille elle est en tournée à partir
du 23 septembre 2006 et ensuite à
l'olympia le 26 décembre le lendemain de
noël horrible à la dinde tout va être
encore plus dur qu aujourd'hui la lettre
du 26 au 31 passer les dernières
dernière de ce spectacle tu prépares tu
en one man en ce moment est ce que
laurent il en fait un la loi de man
c'est alors le moment ce one man ça
avance grave dis moi une vanne pour voir
grave je vais l'écrire au fur et à
mesure les gens vont venir me voir sur
scène donc tout n'est pas encore
déterminé à tuer ces working princesse
voilà ça s'appelle une escroquerie
t'as pas une vanne là qu'on voit non non
non non ça c'est pour les payer en seuil
atteint le nombre sommes des comics et
qui font des vagues gratos ont pour nom
de salat bien
ça va être soeur j'avais très cher se
mettre hors de prix ça va être hors de
prix dans des endroits reculés ce sera
pas facile de trouver un endroit ce sera
très cher et l'accueil n'y allez pas
c'est une merde j'espère mais non je
vais ap le one man je vais l'appeler
complet
c'est unanime tu peux l'appeler complet
oui à rester à l'affiché d'un film aussi
où il s'appelle dikkenek oui 1 avec
marion cotillard catherine jacob
dominique pinon jérémie renier et là
vous jouez un flic à une flic lesbiennes
ça m'a pas échappé il dit lesbienne
parce qu'ils voient plein d'image il ya
plein de cassettes vidéo qui défile en
bas c'est à cause du calibre c'est ça le
hockey sereine oui c'est ça en fait le
réalisateur qui est un bel c'est son
premier film m'avait contacté ya
longtemps et puis on savait pas vraiment
pour quel rôle c'est un rôle masculin au
départ donc voilà on l'a tout simplement
rendu femmes et lesbiennes voilà mais
dans la vie ça vous intéresse les flics
lesbiennes oui non ni l'un ni l'autre
bref en tout cas vous avez des problèmes
avec les mecs quand même ah bon derrière
vous dit de faire rire ou séduire il
faut choisir
non mais je trouve que ces deux sources
différentes la séduction comme on
l'entend pas dans un couple et puis
faire rire c'est pour moi quand on me
dira sur scène pourquoi vous épandre
décolleté ou tient sur scène est ce que
vous pensez être belle tout ça je trouve
que ces deux terrains très très très
distincts en ce qui me concerne en tout
cas pas on n'est pas sur celle pour se
faire la belle voilà c'est ça il est
toujours entre une bonne blague et une
belle paire de seins on choisira
toujours la belle paire de seins les
armes choisiront toujours là c'est pas
très grave c'est comme ça que l'homme
est fait ouais non mais c'est vrai
anggun sers tu peux le faire rire tant
que tu veux s'il ya une bombe qui arrive
bombe à la bombe
bonsoir
mais tu as juste et que maicon est
ouvert à tous elle demande le tessin bon
c'est normal c'est bien la nature c'est
dans la nature des choses c'est pas très
grave j'aimerais que les femmes rigolote
ça fait peur mais qu'en plus c'est vrai
non ça je suis pas sûr ça c'est le fil
entre elles qui se disent ouais je pense
que je ne fais pas
la refermant des hommes qui adore les
femmes drôles singes aurait jamais de
mecs ça serait horrible il y en a qui
adore avoir une femme drôle parce qu'ils
veulent pas dans leur couple avoir juste
une fille comme ça avec qui son temps à
peu pratique et très belle ils ont
besoin de sous ils ont envie de se
marrer il y en a heureusement et anggun
torneo toi tu vois on ne regarde
hervé lucas en matière de drague j'ai dû
fournir deux fois plus d'efforts que les
autres filles quoi
non enfin faut choisir la cible c'est à
qui ça sert à rien en effet
non mais ça sert à rien de draguer un
homme à mort comme un mec qui rit pas
avec les femmes je veux dire mais
qu'attend une fille très docile très tu
vois très pratique
voilà bon ça ne sert à rien donc là hop
tu change de cible ouais bon le mec un
peu moins beau tout ça mais ils se
marient
en grès du succès i'm a man that all ça
marche énorme pot non ça va me longtemps
sa vie quand même temps sérieux je sais
pas parce que 8,2 en quoi à peu près au
même moment je suis arrivé à paris oui
les quatre saisons il a fallu qu'il
attend de 62 ans oui puis il a beaucoup
plu sera mai
gfr bras de fer tu vois c'est un cible
vers laquelle je n'irai pas d'instinct
non c'est vrai qu'il fait un peu peur il
est impressionnante et très gentille
comprend pas la moitié de ce que tu lui
dises un très bon gars
mais je l'aimé j'ai beaucoup ri oui j'ai
vu
là vous êtes formidables merci qui est
formidable
j'adore j'ai beaucoup ri
michel jetté bien une petite chanson
pour toi là abo une chanson que j'adore
alors égaliser
anggun elle m'a dit c'est bruel oui bien
vous avez gagné
la baisse
non mais ça parce que vous êtes toujours
avec les nouveaux magnifiques là non
absolument en tournée ça se passe bien
c'est super bien marché normes super
bien je vais je vais la dernière date de
la saison je vais faire à ramatuelle au
festival de ramatuelle c'est un endroit
un théâtre en plein air j'adore cet
endroit non non ça marche très bien
vraiment 2 et 3 décembre toi tu fais
l'olympia oui pour la sortie du dvd
dont un geek - juillet au zénith de
paris donc rire contre le racisme
il ya encore des places à vendre vous
pouvez vous adresser au site internet
qui s'affiche en ce moment au bas de
votre écran magie la télévision et en
attendant on va faire un raciste quiz
mais bon
bonjour tout le monde voit si je vous
dis ah bon vous dit ahmed bien
qu est ce que les immigrés vient de
faire en france
mangez pas des
personnages de contes
démissionna les yeux je vois ta carte du
front national qu'est ce que les noirs
aux une grosse
non non
non c'est géré ses temps la réponse ah
bon c'est parce que tu es là la réponse
des massifs le sens du rythme ah oui le
sentir il saura si c'est vrai faire
un travail bâclé c'est un travail
d'arabe bien jouer un point tu vas y
seraient pas
en danger
ça me fait penser c'est pas à verser une
histoire drôle est plus courte que je
connaisse au monde c'est l'histoire d'un
juif qui rencontre un autre arabe
il y en a des raisons ils vont
comprendre mais c'est pas grave
attention très bon vous êtes prêts
laurent les antilles et sont tous des
lézardes sont tous des c'est pas voleur
bravo bien sûr le sujet sensible du
recul sur les juifs mais j'en arrivais
musulmans sont tous des
ddt que des terroristes bravo maintient
les juifs les juifs sont tous ah ah ah
oui à deauville oui bravo
non les portugaises sont toutefois lui
prenne soin les jours toi tu veux
rajouter
alors attention qui a tout petit sexe
chinois wahaha
dairy soufflage
de la part d'un orque en rien un diable
rouge qui n'a pas d'humour les anglais
n'ont finalement oui ah oui
exactement et quand moi je sors une
bonne réponse personne n'applaudit
m
rentré chez votre mais
qui sont tous fait des progrès ouais
vous les anglais mais les grecs si
tu voulais te voyais mal de monde mais
je dois faire
mes chiens bronzer à mykonos 20 minutes
sur le banc jay boîte et pendant quinze
jours
[Musique]
donc capable keaven les poulets roulent
en mercedes et je tombe bien ouais j'ai
choisi
moi c'est bien on est raciste et pas
envie d'abîmer put de colombie non c'est
la côte
ouest voilà de la jeunesse est pas loin
quel chanteur décédé a dit n'y a pas de
civilisation noire si on avait une on la
connait trés les noirs n'ont pas
construit notre dame les pires amis de
la tour eiffel un mais à part ça
je connais pas
mais un mec libéral ont un peu réac
il connaît chaque année là il a
également dit la vérité sort de la
bouche des enfants ces dames en one man
une collègue gratos et crysis 2 qui a
dit afrique c'est très simple je vais
vous expliquer ces noirs et ça grouille
acquéreurs
rappel non non
un chanteur non un homme politique
profond oui de villiers non non pasqua
non non c'est un mec on s'attend pasqua
c'est ça l'afrique c'est très simple je
vous expliquer ces noirs et ça grouille
il faut être gonflé pour quand même pas
de gaulle si non
je trop forte ou pas été trop forte car
mémoire ex-aequo et ma fille qui a
chanté au temps béni des colonies
sauvages bien du soufflage mais s'est
dit charly sur meetic de voir le père
delanoë nom mais qui a dit il ya quand
même moins d'étrangers que de raciste en
france coluche que oui absolument
[Musique]
et
3 juillet au juste
[Musique]
et
belga
mais c'est ta culotte en partant la gtv
nous laisser voir les textos dans notre
portable
non
non parce que qu'ils sont pas tu vois
des cailloux je t'emmerde faumontois
vous devez prendre la place de thierry
ardisson et faire tout ce que vous
voulez pendant deux minutes
si l'émission est lui aussi en pige en
cas de bataille et fontaine déjà j'aime
bien vous devez dire une énorme connerie
n'importe laquelle
les joueurs ont une grosse
monsieur l'usma
alors
qu'arte milla jovovich
vous devez jeter un verre d'eau sur
l'animateur à la première occasion même
pas enlève deux mois une note il est
gentil tu as vu gentil non je suis
inquiet pour l'eau
car ce paris s'il tonne vous devez
donner le numéro de téléphone personnel
d'une ses limites est présente dans
votre répertoire même pas en rêve du nom
je fais comme toi pourquoi non
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin et je vais
même lire celles qui sont pas écrites
quart-temps faire vous devez crié gloire
à satan et tant pis pour les
conséquences arrêt électrique concept
question de mois note
car brigitte bardot vous devez dire du
mal d'un arabe au hasard bemba aurait
brassé beaucoup giga mais il ya
tellement de jeux vidéo et les aldéhydes
haye mais il ya plein de gens que j'ai
du mal des arabes j'adore j'ai bien dit
dan vas-y pour une nonne en ce moment il
ya pas mal de gens qui disent du mal de
zidane on j'ai entendu à la télé genre
il est fatigué j'aurais juste et plus
jouer au foot genre il faut qu'il rentre
chez sa mère l'a dit quand même non ça
c'est ce que les gens disent oui je
pense pas ça un montage en gardera que
ta phrase
je m'en fous voilà lui c'est easy zizou
et moi nous savons tous et de cartes
question vous avez le droit de poser une
question un autre invité
ghosn
tu veux que je pose une question en
gaule portable portable
il faut que je demande son numéro est ce
qu un goon vous pouvez me donner votre
numéro de portable parce que tirer
audition il le veut
après moi je vais lui donner à privas
voir celer toute la nuit je suis à
cannes afin fatigué vous lui dites
d'accord vient non c'est pour lui moi je
peux pas ah ah ah parce qu'à moi vous
leur donneriez attendait
[Musique]
olivier je voulais faire partir sans les
merlots attaque merci merci merci
[Musique]
quand
j'accueille véronique jannot et mélanie
maudran
magnifique cette véronique jannot elle
elle est jolie elle est mignonne regarde
et l'autre un temps non
pas du tout non pas du tout mélanie pas
du tout mais c'est vrai véronique moi
j'ai une quelque chose dans le regard
alain espèces de
coquillages ouais ça va ça va alors vous
êtes ici toutes les deux pour parler de
la saga de l'été de france 2 qui
s'appelle les secrets du volcan alors au
départ ça s'appelait cases créoles après
ça s'appelait les yeux du volcan après
ça s'est attelée des enfants du volcan
maintenance appelle les secrets du
volcan enfin faut dire que ça se passe
et la réunion d'où le volcan c'est une
histoire qui respecte le principe des
grandes sagas ici c'est basé sur
l'archétype de roméo et juliette
il ya deux grandes familles l'émail et
les bertin deux familles rivales qui se
haïssent et les deux rejetons ce m et
voilà l'intrigué les capulet l'exemple
un gala fin merci on va
bien sûr y ait du crime arias du crime
un viaduc eu ou pas un peu oui bien sûr
mais aussi en profiter comme il ya de
l'amour mais la saga qui a tué qui est
inquiet tchéquie justement
comme un épisode 4 au mois d'août voilà
les secrets du volcan marc l'eau autour
de véronique la série votre dernière
apparition c'était clair bellac sur tf1
ouais c'est une émission qui accule
arrêté malgré de bonnes audiences c'est
toujours drôle les missions qu'on arrête
avec de bruno senna en dépit des vives
oui c'est des fidèles ont arrêté alors
la vôtre mais je ne sais pas je ne peux
pas c'est quelque chose que j'ai
toujours en travers de la gorge c'est le
barrage il pense pas parce que c'est que
j'ai pas compris donc je n'ai toujours
pas compris aujourd'hui mais pourquoi
non mais fait un truc regardez votre
caméra la cola c'est le cas de rouge et
dit étienne pourquoi m'as-tu arrêté ma
série
non non c'est pas fâché avec les
bisous à l'epo ce bisou
je ne
comment je vais faire moi sur une autre
chaîne donc l'année prochaine si j'ai pu
c'est fou ce bisou et comment je vais
faire quand vous ne voulez une pause
bezos je crois en dieu tu ne passes pas
le tour michel pousse bisous moi même
pas en rêve
c'est votre premier rôle de méchante ah
oui c'est un vrai rôle de méchante c'est
la méchante de du film stone tabasser
c'est parfois c'est la première fois
très sympa très gentille et là mais
c'est assez jubilatoire de mon pays
c'est vrai que dans le cadre d'une saga
c'est ce genre de chose en plus qu'on se
permette un jeu machiavélique sans
scrupules enfer horrible tout y'a pas un
défaut cas l'appa est donc vous êtes
opposée à melanie 1 voilà moi je suis
mais elle est une bertin c'est une
bertin alors on va voir à quoi ça
ressemble vous allez regarder toutes les
deux votre caméra c'est le cas le rouge
et comme serge est revenue vous avez
dire magnéto serge et non pas magnéto
richard parce que ça ne partirai pas je
vais en même temps 1 2 3 magnéto serge
bien
[Musique]
l'échangé ctions
les bertin l émail qui se parlent de
passer à tout d'abord pourquoi c'est la
reine de toutes les générations
pourquoi les mâts et parce que ce sont
les ennemis des bertin que comme par
hasard il se retrouve avec un cadavre
sur les bras fais moi confiance
n'ont pas choisi le bon moment où tu met
il pas l'endroit pourquoi tu fais tous
apprendre j'ai besoin de toi
well as a laissé près du volcan c'est la
saga c'est sur france 2 monsieur
scénario jamaica toi
quelques rois maudits se découvre je
n'ai rien vu encore le tournage a lieu
en pleine épidémie de chikungunya
ça a été terrible et psychose totale à
psychose totale
volonté beaucoup beaucoup par parler les
nouvelles de métropole sur un parce que
là-bas en fait ça se vivait très
différemment de ce qu'on pouvait dire
ici c'était il y avait c'est vrai il y
avait il y avait un risque qu'il y avait
un danger mais on pouvait se protéger en
étant vigilant c'est ce qu'on a tous
fait c'était c'était fallait vraiment
chier de me faire piquer quand même de
temps en temps vous avez été piqué par
un ouais comme les 5 à 12 jours
d'incubation on comptait les jours parce
qu'on savait pas si c'était le nouvel
empire sur les routes
y en a qu'on voulu partir il ya eu c'est
vrai un moment une
une psychose un petit peu sur sur le
tournage mais il ya eu un grand élan de
solidarité vraiment tous décidé de
rester parce qu'il y avait quand même
faut pas l'oublier avec toute une équipe
réunionnaise à bavay quand même 60% 70%
de réunionnais qui se retrouvaient
planté là sinon si on partait je
travaille pas et en plus c'est vrai que
pour lille c'était important aussi qu'on
reste parce que ça a été catastrophique
pour économiquement c'est moi je devais
jouer là-bas s'était dégonflée non les
assurances n'ont pas voulu que je parte
à la suite d'une déclaration d'un d'un
homme politique à la télé il est où il
disait il ya eu dias je sais pas combien
de milliers de gens contaminés et le
journaliste lui disais mais ce que est
ce qu on a une réponse thérapeutique et
il a dit non il faut qu'on vive avec le
lendemain matin j'avais un coup
téléphone des assurances me disant que
je si je partais je t'ai pas couvert sur
le film et donc
voilà j'ai télé j'étais très malheureux
parce que j'aime beaucoup aller jouer là
bas le public est génial et tous âges
étaient très tristes ne pas pouvoir y
aller moi je partais un mais mais
j'imagine
j'imagine l' angoisse que ça pouvait
générer méga vraiment il y avait
l'angoissé il y avait vraiment il y
avait aussi beaucoup de bonheur avec là
bas aussi venir c'était pas
oui c'est que je joue là bas tu fait un
triomphe tous les cas vous vous êtes
resté très courageusement très zen en
fait vous êtes bouddhiste c'est pas pour
ça que je suis zen mais on est quand
même non maintenant ça fait ça fait
longtemps que je suis alors dans cette
vous avez découvert le bouddhisme auprès
d'une personne proche qui lutter contre
une maladie en récitant une phrase un
mantra est ce que c'est une amie au ring
et kyo en l'occurrence c'était ça
n'hésitez pas seulement ça c'était une
pratique beaucoup plus approfondie du
connaissent alors oui
c'est le son qui est produit par la
répétition de cette phrase à une
fonction sur le sur le cerveau c'est
vrai c'est parce que c'est se concentrer
en fait sur un mantra fixer son
attention et ça permet de 2,2 de
relation par là dedans de faire le vide
en fait et dans ses comptes en tant que
centre profond parce qu'on se pose et
l'esprit arrêtent de travailler de
travailler tout le temps les gens sous
vide
non non justement on est plein mais ne
soit pas l'extérieur voilà vous ai fait
un livre qui s'appelle trouver le chemin
chez michel lafon ouais vous n'êtes pas
venu en parler ici non parce que j'en ai
pas aller chez fogiel sera dit c'est
fogiel ardisson et comme les dates
non c'est un problème de bahts en plus
donc oui parce que j'étais en tournée
donc c'est un peu y avait plein de
choses qui peut y ajouter parce que je
les ai lu ce bouquin je trouve ça
vachement bien et aurait dit des choses
formidables sur ce jeu c'est ben oui en
tout cas je sais qu'il a fait beaucoup
de bien à beaucoup de gens et comme il
est je les fais dans ce sens alors
justement dans ce bouquin vous racontez
vous avez un cancer à l'âge de 22 ans
qui vous a empêché de devenir mère à
jamais vous expliquez assez
naturellement d'ailleurs que bon bah
voilà c'était presque un mal pour un
bien vous avez bien profité à toute
épreuve en fait c'est ce et nous
appartient de la transformer de la
dépasser et moi c'est ce que j'ai eu je
crois vraiment le bonheur de faire vous
avez profité bon sur un plan 10 en or
couple un ouais voilà oui vous y voir
oui bah oui oui je pense que avoir un
enfant change change tout dans une vie
un sens de responsabilité qui est
c'est une basse que je pense qu'on a
connue après on a peur de tout le monde
a peur pour eux j'ai souvent que
forcément on fait plus attention à ce
qu'on fait alors que moi je c'est vrai
que je n'ai peur de rien finalement
parce que je n'ai pas peur pour lui vous
avez bien profité on va pas s'appesantir
là dessus ce n'est pas le style de
l'émission c'est profiter la vie voilà
auzits j'étais voilà oui j'étais
maîtresse de la ville oui
voilà on est désolé pas même en profiter
parce qu'on n'essaie pas à l'époque en
même temps et alors non sérieusement au
delà de ça il ya l'humanitaire au
système et s'occupait beaucoup d'enfants
tibétain avec une association qui
s'appelle graines d'avenir pour
préserver la culture de ces enfants qui
ont été obligés souvent de le quitter
leur pays mais pour rester tibétains ils
sont obligés de s'expatrier sont obligés
de traverser l'école himalayens pour
rejoindre l'inde ou en fait le diaspora
tibétaine est établi et maintient la
culture tibétaine impacte donc ses
enfants pour pouvoir être éduqués dans
leur culture pour pouvoir continuer à
apprendre apprendre leur langue en fait
à être élevés dans dans leur langue
maternelle et dans leur culture sont
obligés de s'exiler en inde ça s'arrange
pas cette affaire parce que moi je me
souviens j'avais 10 ans je voyais aux
actualités au cinéma en noir et blanc le
départ du délai lama qui fuyaient le
tibet devant l'avancée des troupes
chinoises
et voilà j'ai 50 ans et aujourd'hui
c'est toujours pas réglé c'est même pire
mais pourquoi est ce que le monde a mis
si longtemps pour regarder ce ce peuple
et pour se rendre compte que en plus
c'est vraiment une culture c'est au-delà
c'est en plus un peuple il ya aussi une
culture c'est kate une richesse
planétaire et dont on n'est pas
conscient c'est une culture
extraordinaire c'est magnifique et ça on
ne le dit pas donc c'est vrai que quand
ce camp je pense j'ai créé cette
association c'est vrai que ces
humanitaires mais c'est au delà j'ai
l'impression de faire en même temps un
devoir d'être humains d'horaires de deux
citoyens du monde devoir de mémoire tous
les pays font du business avec la chine
et la chine n'aime pas du tout qu'on lui
parle de débat pas du tout d'après que
ce que j'ai entendu un des plus jeunes
prisonniers politiques au monde
c'est le fun ce type est un c'était un
matin c'était un tibétain qui a été
enlevée à l'âge de sept ans et qui n'ont
jamais revu et le panchen lama est le
seul qui puisse se reconnaître en fait
le dalaï lama prochain la lie et l'ama
donc c'est dramatique parce qu'ils ont
mis leur punch et cela m'a donc ça veut
dire que le prochain dalaï lama en fête
sera reconnu par les chinois donc c'est
tout cela tout ça est en train de partir
en ce qui est fascinant c'est comment
une puissance aussi grande a peur
d'un pays comme le tibet pour quelles
raisons pour quelles raisons ces géo
géopolitique ils veulent avoir le tibet
dans leur zone d'influencé puis c'est
tout ce que ça 2001
ici
la langue amazighe toi c'est ce qu'ils
veulent quand c'est chez michel lafon
mais si
et
sur l'est où trouver le chemin c'est
aussi ces messieurs la fin mai meyer
[Musique]
faire une interview superstition
attention à ce que vous portez du verre
au théâtre oui je vais te mau corde dans
un théâtre ou sur un plateau l'interdît
non quand ça m'échappe on me dit vous
ramassez les trèfles à quatre feuilles
quand j'ai le bonheur d'en trouver oui
de une patte de lapin chez vous
un sextoy
sa patte de lapin bunny jon tenney déjà
beaucoup de succès c'est une patte de
lapin je te dis pas oui ce serait énorme
et en plus on voulait couper sa
reprocher
mais je me souviens quand j'étais petit
j'avais mis une patte de lapin dans un
sac et en fait je les ouvert quinze
jours après tu
reviens maintenant toujours rage et la
fage et une passe et sous les échelles
vos wii ah ouais ce matin
le seul camp
les femmes sont moins superstitieux mais
sous une échelle moi c'est clair les
hommes sont faites plus peureux plus est
parti sur les femmes juge dubois des
fois tu genre pour conjurer le mauvais
sort ouais j'ai toujours une fois je
croise les doigts ouais tu fais tout
quoi quand et très atteint vite
quelqu'un tu viennes quelques noms en
tresse j'adore à 13 thèmes bien j'adore
mais pour qui c'est un bon chiffre et
12-10 yeux noirs se tapper des chats
noirs fois non j'ai pas peur de chagrin
parce qu'on en a tué beaucoup c'est
comme les chouettes effraies qui sont
les oiseaux magnifique qu'on épingle sur
les granges vous protéger les chouettes
effraies pour mettre des nichoirs voilà
je lis à tout le monde ce sera mon
combat aux mains des nichoirs et c'est
ça que tu vas faire maintenant ben je me
verrais me reconvertir dans la défense
des chouettes effraies c'est pas mal ça
va moins ça va bien dans les chouettes
cantine à rahat et donnera des trucs à
raconter au moins oui on va défendre
quand le pain dans le mauvais sens vous
le mettez de l'autre côté non ah oui bah
voilà un qu'on aime tu jettes du seul
comme ça toi quand il tombe oui mais
vous savez pourquoi que ça porte malheur
non parce que le sel était une denrée
très rare et que si on renversait du sel
comme ça coûtait cher y avait un impôt
sur le sel alors les gens ils se
disputaient alors maintenant le sel on
ne doit pas le passé parce que si jamais
il tombe c'est une superstition qui
vient comme ça du moyen âge voilà qu'il
faut le poser et on le passe c'est un
peu con mais ya plein de gens qui
croient vous savez pourquoi en chine
présent non mais pourquoi leone ont fait
comme ça parce que les types il frappé
leur machin pour que le vin ce mélange
ou là bien ce match comme ça il était
sûr que l'autre il a pas vu de poison
pareil on se serre la main pour montrer
qu'à pas d'armes
exact tout ce départ a pu à l'intérieur
toi non mais ça c'est parce que je suis
pas con
aix a pas de fuites sur tout
[Musique]
trouver le chemin
c'est chez michel lafon à mes yeux
hajnalka toile et ce que nous voulons
c'est chez michel lafon mesdames
messieurs
[Musique]
trois quarts
pas dire magnétosphère jusque là c'était
cool dont vous touche en est ça
l a redit rhmani taussat genre touchant
les
jeux la musique
tu es prête ses traits
[Musique]
à la prime et beaucoup un chat donne
envie de le faire
et bon florent je vous laisser filer à
l'essai une extraction et nord les gens
de voir ces gens là prochaine fois vous
êtes sur scène c'est rire contre le
racisme
ac 2 3 juillet au zénith au génie après
je reprends mon spectacle fin septembre
en tournée dans toute la france attend
quoi entre temps beaucoup de bonheur
merci
il
tiens qu'est roland courbis
comment ça va très très mal très mal et
bernard tapie qui étaient là tout à
l'heure qui a dit qu'il vous aimez
beaucoup de ces récits pro ouais il m'a
dit vraiment je les aime beaucoup c'est
un type formidable et c'est vrai que
j'avais des soucis en ce moment le jour
de l'ouverture de la coupe du monde de
football vous avez été condamné rolland
courbis par le tribunal correctionnel de
marseille à deux ans de prison ferme
375 mille euros d'amendé et cinq ans
d'interdiction
d'exercer une activité dans le milieu du
football tout ça pour abus de biens
sociaux le fameux abs comme on dit
maintenant au sujet du procès des
comptes de l'om et vous allez repris 18
mois de prison supplémentaires pascal
révocation évidemment d'un sursis
précédent voilà vous dites la sanction
me paraît disproportionnée en
correctionnelle c'est pas à huis clos il
ya un filament de gens écrit fisam ans
de témoins pour que et puis ressortir
une chose au moins une seule c'est que
je n'ai volé personne pas plus
l'olympique de marseille qui s'est porté
partie civile et qui rentrait dans les
cordes que robert louis dreyfus qui se
retrouve lui aussi condamné en tant
qu'auteur et moisson son complice donc
on n'est pas là pour juger des lois on
est là pour se défendre toujours est il
qu on se défendra du mieux possible
maintenant en appel on va présenter un
dossier sur dix transferts je suis
condamné sur cinq relaxes et sur cinq
autres ces serments je sais pas pourquoi
je suis condamné je sais pas pourquoi je
suis relax et les dix mêmes donc
derrière ça je vois une sévérité que je
ne m'explique pas je pensais avoir
collaboré entre guillemets avec un juge
et se chante pour lui expliquer le plus
que je pouvais lui expliquer pareil pour
un président de
un tribunal c'est vrai qu'il ya une
coïncidence vous l'avez présenté que une
condamnation aussi sévère me soit donné
le jour de l'ouverture
j'apprécie quand même j'apprécie quand
même cette façon de me présenter les
choses je sais que en interne à
l'olympique de marseille alors que nous
étions en train de jouer le titre nous
avons été bousillée par les nôtres je
pensais que si un jour on pouvait nous
nous emmerder entre guillemets salaires
de nos adversaires là non là on joue le
titre avec bordeaux on oublie en interne
dans quel but dans ce but peut être de
devenir dirigeant puisque cet effet par
des anciens dirigeants certainement il
ya des choses que je m'explique d'autres
que je ne m'explique pas vous parler
d'extermination à votre rencontre dans
le milieu du football heureusement vous
avez fait appel parce que ça vous évite
la prison immédiate évidemment là
heureusement je fais appel ok mais quand
par exemple que mes amis mais ça c'est
pas une condamnation et c'est sévère
c'est un assassinat mais sinon c'est pas
un assassinat parce qu'un assassinat
timor timon l'asse on enterre vivants
alors évidemment je vais faire le
maximum pour lutter essayé d'expliquer
aux gens que nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans deux délits à la mode la bsl avec
biens sociaux la b2 et sociaux la
complicité d'un bs moi comme je mène une
vie originale en tant que complice je
suis plus sévèrement condamnés que
l'auteur ça il faudra qu'on m'explique
général intellectuellement quand on
m'explique je comprends et un deuxième
délit à la mode ou la jeu la pédophilie
est donc c'est à dire que la méthode je
fais gaffe parce que quand niang hausse
de 12 ans qui est de me faire signer et
machins et que j'avais l'habitude de lui
caresser la tête
qu'elle produit
savent à quel poste toujours parce que
arriver certains moments alors que j'ai
toujours eu confiance
là j'ai totalement perdu confiance en
moi ce qui m'est reproché pour répondre
à votre question c'est donc de
participer à des réunions les réunions
sont faites pour choisir sportivement
les joueurs choisir leur complémentarité
et essayer avec le handicap france et
que nous avons dans la structure fiscale
qui est la nôtre de voir comment l'on
peut faire pour disons que ça nous coûte
le moins est aussi en gros vous cherchez
des astuces pour faire venir des joueurs
donc l'abri mais ce que j'appelle des
astuces moi est que nous appelons nous
le désastre us la justice elle fait
appel ça irrégularités et sincèrement et
là je jure sur tous ceux que j'ai de
plus cher la différence qu'il ya entre
l'as tu ce que nous pensons au club et
les irrégularités que pense la justice
je ne l'est toujours pas compris à ce
jour pour moi par exemple quand on me
dit tiens dans le transfert on va papa
cité en exemple un exemple le transfert
de laurent blanc l'ongle à barcelone
donc vous dirigez de marseille et toi le
confisque assistent à cette réunion qui
n'a même pas la possibilité de signer
quoi que ce soit je n'ai pas la
signature donc il ya une possibilité
grâce entre guillemets à la structure
fiscale espagnole si une partie du
transfert qui remis à laurent blanc ça
nous fait nous français économiser on va
pas les chiffres c'est le transfert de
laurent blanc 2 millions de dollars 1
l'olympique de marseille rajoute un
million de dollars ça fait 3 millions de
dollars le mieux est remis en espagne
par les dirigeants espagnols à laurent
blanc on n'est même pas censé savoir si
la déclaration ne déclare pas et là où
il ya quand même un point important
qu'il faudra vérifier d'ailleurs vous
pouvez il ya suffisamment d'auditeurs
pour qui a hérité journalistes quand il
ya un transfert barcelone l'olympique de
marseille pourquoi nous sommes obligés
d'être dans une situation française et
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas dans une
situation espagnole d'un transfert
achats et ventes et si nous sommes dans
une situation espagnole nous sommes
innocents donc nous français si j'ai
bien compris on voudrait qu'on paye
trois fois plus cher un joueur que
l'italien et l'allemand l'anglais et
l'espagnol et quand nous faisons une
réunion qui aboutit justement à ce que
met on n'a pas envie d'être plus de
chercher des excuses regrettant plus que
nous jouerons la champions league contre
ces clubs là mais ça s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé à laurent blanc ça c'est un
abs et moi j'ai chaque piste isabelle
c'est à dire comme vous explique aussi
en français
vous porter préjudice à votre club en
lui faisant économiser 2 millions de
dollars mais moi quand je fais
économiser 2,2 millions de dollars à mon
club je ne me sens pas une irrégularité
et encore moins un préjudice est la
meilleure à l'épreuve c'est que ce club
qui s'appelle l'olympique de marseille
quand il se porte partie civile et qui
demandent 3 millions d'euros de dommages
intérêts contre les éventuels irrégulier
que nous aurions pu être nous ils sont
renvoyés ouais j'ai vu ils sont déboutés
oui donc j'ai du mal à comprendre
maintenant maintenant il ya une justice
je suis là pour aller jusqu'au bout et
je peux même vous dire les choses si je
dois faire de la prison je pourrais de
la présence j'ai pris un coup de frein
c'est ce que disait tapis tout à l'ère
tapie dit le problème c'est que tous les
joueurs allemands qui sont au mondial il
joue en allemagne les italiens les gens
utilisent l'espère une jeune espagne des
français jouent pas en france c'est à
dire qu'ils sont vides et jouer à
l'extérieur pour des raisons fiscales
que que vous évoquez a serré que ça vous
met dans une situation compliquée vous
ça c'est sûr non plus bon sens puisque
plus que compliquée jeu il va falloir
que j'attende encore une quinzaine de
mois pour me retrouver un appel à aix 1
sans être sûr de rien parce que celui
qui pensent que parce qu'on va y changer
de juridiction par contre ce dont j'ai
pas tellement apprécié c'est que vous
savez pour moi je défende le système
d'arbitrage dans le football là je
compare un petit peu les différents ces
étapes
du système judiciaire comme aussi un
système d'arbitrage il ya un juge après
un président qui est en temps de
systématiquement en cours de procès mais
vous irex vous irex par moments je me
demande pourquoi ne pas aller tout de
suite rex parce que ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que à l'intérieur de ce système on
juge le commerce que peut être un
transfert mais moi quand je paye mes
avocats que je payais mes avocats à en
appel que je payais mes avocats pendant
un procès que maintenant paraît-il mes
avocats ils sont pas suffisamment bonnes
parce que si on doit aller en cassation
il faut même que je paye nous allons
évoquer sur la cour de cassation service
apprécié ça par contre c'est pas un
commerce et vous entendre dire alors que
vous êtes là pour nous défendre pour
expliquer que bon c'est un truc là vous
irez vous direct alors sincèrement
quelque part ça a été pour moi un
portable mais on ira ex c'est un peu le
cauchemar la pauvre ce pire que ça puis
bon je suis pas là pour attendre et les
gens
j'ai beaucoup souffert depuis cinq ans
que l'on puisse
déjà dans une situation de présomption
d'innocence me faire aucun cadeau à la
limite cette sévérité dans le procès
je suis pas d'accord mais je la
comprends mais la sévérité
depuis cinq ans alors que je dois être
normalement dans la situation française
dans une présomption d'innocence je vais
vous dire un truc celui qui ouvre le
journal et qu'il y tient cet entraîneur
là il s'appelle roland courbis ajaccio
en interdit d'entrée nage action car
dans six mois il ya une question que je
pose le juge d'instruction puisque c'est
lui qui a décidé ça c'est que je n'ai
pas compris pourquoi n'ont pas été
interdits d'entrée n'a cherché j'ai pas
compris pourquoi j'étais autorisé au
match retour d'entraîner à ajaccio et là
je vous faire une confidence mais
aujourd'hui la vérifier c'est que j'ai
une mer moins aussi à la lecture de de
ce contrôle judiciaire entre le montant
de la caution l'interdition
de me regarder comme ça me dit mais
qu'est ce tu as fais
pas ma mère ma mère et six jours après
elle avait la maladie de parkinson c'est
une coïncidence c'est une coïncidence
qui aujourd'hui me reste en travers de
la gorge parce que je pense qu'on aurait
pu être moins patient d'attendre le
procès et si après le procès on veut
pour x raisons de ce soir me traiter
avec plus de sévérité que ce que je
pense mériter au moins pour le faso le
jour du procès là vous avez des idées
noires et peut faire une connerie au
moins
si je faisais la moitié de ce que je
rêve
la nuit ça serait plus que grave mais
bon quand même beaucoup de cachet un
petit peu donc pour essayer de dormir
mais bon je pense que j'ai aussi des
obligations des obligations pour mes
proches pour ma famille pour ceux qui
m'aiment bien de me battre et essayer de
démontrer que malgré ce gros pépin
qui m'arrive j'arriverai à le surmonter
est bon comme je dis
tu arrivé quand même être champion de
france eva beau finir dreyfus lui mais
130 millions d'euros dans le club on
l'accuse d'abus de biens sociaux c'est
bizarre quand même aussi là c'est vrai
que
chaque fois qu'on m'arrête dans la rue
pour me demander mais alors comment
monsieur robert louis dreyfus il met des
sous venant du lycée en france mais là
c'est une évasion fiscale c'est pas une
hérésie anormalement bas
est-ce que départ est ce qu'au départ
l'histoire qui aujourd'hui est pas grand
chose est ce qu'au départ l'histoire
s'était pas de se demander d'où venait
l'argent comme ils arrivaient des jeunes
taguent est ce qu'on n'a pas imaginé des
choses sur l'argent que robert
louis-dreyfus mettait dans le club c'est
parce que c'est pas ça qui a démarré
d'histoire c'est des bruits que j'ai
entendu les bruits que j'ai entendu
d'ailleurs il ya une demande sur ces
dossiers une démonstration que peut-être
je dis bien peut-être c'est ça parce que
si je dis bien si
on avait cherché dans cette enquête
des salariés de l'om avec des
compléments de salaires après le salé
aux blacks appelle ça comme vous voulez
exonérée d'impôt ou défiscalisées
je pense pas
qu'on aurait comme retrouver uniquement
moi et comme rechercher uniquement - le
boulot ou alors peut-être que je me
trompe le boulot de la justice c'est de
chercher les irrégularités c'est pas de
chercher uniquement les irrégularités de
tyria hardy sol ou de roland
courbin que des fois je dis à mes amis
j'ai dit c'est quand même extraordinaire
parce que finalement nous participons à
des réunions rauque et je suis comme
piste d'albert ça va mais avocats ils
m'ont expliqué mais les transferts ce
sont quand même des transferts de
joueurs se sont pas d'être alster de
voitures les joueurs ici en place et
jouer sans pas le tribunal temps de
parler j'ai pas pour habitude de me
défendre en disant tiens je ne réponde à
des questions je vais vous donner deux
trois adresses derrière qu'ils ont fait
pire que moi non je réponse mais jusqu'à
une certaine
limite nous faisons nos réunions ces
fameuses réunions dont je suis le
complice pour qu'un transfert aboutisse
et que s'il ya eu un montage astucieux
c'est pas mal ramé nîmois qui à l'époque
allait profiter c'est un joueur ils ont
peut-être oublié que j'étais joueur donc
je vais peut-être dans ma des phases de
leur dire je suis ex joueur peut-être
que je vais te considérer comme les
joueurs donc je sais pas plus maintenant
je sais pas de quelle façon on va se
défendre vous venez finalement peut-être
de me donner une idée c'est compliqué
tout ça
voilà on va faire une interview moralité
est-ce que vous avez déjà touché de
l'argent sur le transfert d'un joueur
oui pour le transfert de bas payés par
milan est-ce que vous avez déjà gonflé
le prix d'un joueur pour prendre votre
part non jamais est-ce que vous avez
déjà ici d'acheter un arbitre non jamais
est-ce que vous avez déjà ici de louer
un arbitre est ce que vous êtes déjà
demandé un joueur adverse de lever le
pied
non jamais ça se fait que jamais mais
quand j'étais joueur par contre essayé
d'impressionner impressionner
l'adversaire direct pendant le match oui
vous avez déjà joué la titularisation
d'un joueur pour un match au poker non
j'ai jamais joué au poker 1
contrairement à ce qu'on pense que ce
cola cola dit il ya beaucoup de choses
donc qu'il faut que je rectifie par
exemple je suis interdit de casino
depuis 1982 je rencontre des gens qui me
diallo casinos belges et casino c'était
une époque de ma vie qui s'est terminée
à 90 excuse et déjà mis des médicaments
dans l'eau minérale de vos adversaires
non mais ce qu'ils aient déjà enterré de
l'argent au fond d'un jardin non plus
exagérer une caisse noire à toulon
on en avait parlé c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être que ce qui s'est passé à tous
leurs 1990 mme pourtaud toro jours ça a
été le début des emmerdes relance oui
oui oui alors que bon on s'est pas
réveillé un matin à toulon en disant
tiens si on titille malhonnête ce matin
à ses cours au troisième joueur nous
avons voulu faire signer chaque fois il
nous disait ma prime à la signature tous
les clubs me l'a donnée au black black
black aussi rien n'est bon ben voilà
vous êtes déjà dénoncé un ami pour être
innocenté non oui déjà fouillé dans le
sac de votre mère comme ses petits
fouillé non mais me piquer quelques
quelques fois pour aller acheter chez
une norme soit oui oui déjà copié sur
votre voisin l'école systématiquement
excuse et déjà reçu des valises d'argent
liquide jamais vous avez déjà dit
monsieur le juge je suis innocent c'est
les autres qui sont coupables non mais
déjà conduit une voiture volée non plus
j'ai triché à un examen
essayez ça oui
mais bon une fois je me suis fait
attraper déjà profiter de votre
célébrité pour draguer une fille rolland
tombée vous étiez à tricher sur votre
déclaration d'impôts ben disons que j'ai
suffisamment
depuis 20 ans une grosse loupe que même
je voudrais ce serait très difficile à
ne pas dire impossible mais déjà eu
envie de tuer quelqu'un
assez souvent la dernière personne vous
ayez envie de tuer c'est qui
je vais oublier le rêve que j'ai fait la
donne 1 1 comme je suis quand même jugé
avec beaucoup de sévérité je me
demandais si des fois dans un rêve je
pourrais pas être dans une espèce de
tentative de meurtre c'est comme ça donc
pu chauffer grave ça commence par un des
ceux là il me fait il me il me met même
pas les boules et me fait de la peine 1
regardez tf1 ne s'amuse pas
pourquoi regarder france 2 voilà
il
et
j'accueille monsieur r
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
alors monsieur r vous êtes un rappeur et
en mars 2005 j'ai sorti un disque de rap
intitulé politiquement incorrect et sur
ce disque il ya une chanson qui
s'appelle france avec deux aces comme ss
et vous dites dans ce disque la france
est une garce n'oublie pas de la baiser
jusqu'à l'épuiser comme une il
faut la traiter mecque et vous ajoutez
je pisse sur napoléon et le général de
gaulle henri iv louis xiv non non non
non mais déjà faut commencer par le
début c'est qu'au tout début du morceau
pour que les gens comprennent très bien
c'est que je commence par dire quand je
parle de la franche parle pas du peuple
français mais des dirigeants de l'état
français ouais donc après moi j'ai pas
trop d'affinités avec napoléon puisque
c'est lui qui a rétabli l'esclavagé à
son époque et pas trop d'affinités avec
de gaulle parce que là participé aussi à
la colonisation ainsi c'est lui qui a
décolonisé mais la terre est colonisée
par parce que en fait les peuples les
peuples que ce soit en algérie ou que ce
soit en afrique noire se révoltaient
qu'à partir de ce verger au goal qui a
fait l égalisation quand il l'a fait
mais pas de son plein gré en fin de
l'effet même si la fed n'a pas fait de
son plein gré à campsas et des paroles
de la chanson donc je pisse sur napoléon
et sur deux vols de gaulliste
ouais je vise je crois qu'il va venir
injections sont aimés alors il ya un
clip aussi alors dans le clip ya une
rencontre très très amicale entre chirac
et mobutu l'ex dictateur du zaïre dans
votre famille est originaire dégénère et
pierre des images montrant des soldats
de l'armée française tirant sur des
civils ivoiriens et vous vous êtes
déguisé en soldat vous rappelle avec
deux marianne nu qui se frotte contre le
drapeau bleu blanc rouge c'est vraiment
été le hasard c'est qu'en fait un jour
j'étais dans un studio est en fait le
le journaliste qui avait fait le
reportage justement devant l'hôtel
ivoire en fait à pau d'ivoire et il m'a
dit enfin j'ai des images qui prouvent
que
que les militaires français avaient tiré
moi je dis bon je demande qu'à voir
parce que moi j'ai vu à la télé j'ai
regardé toutes les chaînes de télé j'ai
vu la ministre de la défense nous dire
qu'ils n'avaient pas tiré et que c'était
le peuple qui avançaient et qu'il était
armé et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont tiré
mais par sommation en fait et pourquoi
montrer ces images là je me suis dit
mais attendez il ya quand même une
désinformation et à partir de là est
venue ce morceau là et je me suis
rappelé d'un reportage que j'avais vu de
france 5 où je me rappelle j'étais jeune
on voyait en fait chirac en 74 en train
de dire la france aime mobutu et moi
j'ai vécu pendant 30 ans dans trois ans
haïr et j'ai pas un bon souvenir de lui
en fait j'ai un souvenir ou un ubuntu
tué des millions de personnes il
s'éteint un dictateur sanguinaire et je
me suis rappelé de tout ça je me suis
dit mais attendez trop désinformation
quand c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses je ne pense pas que le peuple
français soit on amitié avec mobutu 1 et
je me suis dit mais il ya trop d
information un moment donné faut faut
moi en tant que rappeur moi je me
considère comme un mini journalistes
entre guillemets je me suis dit il faut
quand même que la vérité se sache voilà
donc quand même à donner ces images là
je me suis dit je veux montrer aux yeux
de tout le monde regardez ce que les
militaires français font en côte
d'ivoire on nous parle la france pays
des droits de l'homme
la france est quand même un pays qui qui
aux yeux du monde quand même c'est un
pays qui est démocratique et tout ça me
regarde et les soldats français sous les
ordres des gens qui sont qui sont au
pouvoir les présidents de la république
et les ministres de la défense regarder
ce que les militaires français sont
capables de faire en afrique alors que
je me pose sur la question imaginez-vous
que demain
il ya souvent en plus souvent des
agriculteurs qui rentre dans des
grands des grandes surfaces et qui
détruisent plus imaginez vous une
seconde que des militaires français se
mettent à tirer sur des gens qui sont
désarmés imaginez vous ce que ça
pourrait faire aux yeux des gens et moi
je me suis dit il faudrait que les gens
sachent réellement ce que l'état
français c'est à dire l'état français
pas le peuple mais ce que l'état
français les dirigeants français sont
capables de faire dans des pays sous
développés et des pays et surtout ce qui
m'a vraiment choqué dans cette histoire
c'est que en réfléchissant en naissant
de
cultiver de savoir et tout ça tout les
les connivences qui peut avoir entre les
dictateurs qui sont mises en place et
des fois même
sécurisé par par l'armée française ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire et moi
c'était juge aussi dit à un moment donné
il faut que tout le monde soit au
courant comment les dirigeants français
sa liste le nom de la france au nom de
la france alors que les français eux
mêmes sont ils se sont battus pour la
révolution contre tout ça quoi voilà
donc vous fait cette chanson sur
politiquement incorrect qui s'appelle
france avec deux aces comme ss et là il
ya un député ump qui qui qui voient ce à
quoi qui salent énerve considérablement
il s'appelle daniel mach 1 c'est le
député ump des pyrénées-orientales
ben bella
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors
d'abord l'objet du délit
la piste jusqu'à refuser comme ça
qui se sécher dont à l'arrivée
la france est une mère qui a abandonné
cette nuit sur le trottoir semblent leur
faire ainsi j'ai des lames la fête
voilà on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
j'ai regardé votre caméra monsieur r
voilà c'est le cas de roger vous dites
magnéto serge parce qu'il est revenue là
je veux dire je suis trop content de le
faire parce que tous les samedis je vous
regardez dépêche toi y'a pas moi c'est
clair magnéto serge lafrance et que
c'est plutôt mer quittant enfant tu es
fort et tu les jours du vote n'est
qu'une chose c'est pas avoir à porter si
flamme à celle du stade français le
match au pub sur napoléon le général de
gaulle je crois que leur justice et à
visage humain mais demande à ses fans
déçus qui accouchent menottes à la main
ah non pas pas d'être autonome bono tu
crois que c'est pour rien que lehman
porter pomport le cas coutin faudrait
sur l'iran masques à gaz avant que ça
devienne i n'est pas je remercie pour
leur hospitalité mais mon frère pas tu
passes efforts finissent hospitalisés
suis pas chez moi mais je n'ai rien à
de leur pack la même et à la
française le fauve est une garce
n'oublie pas de l'abaisser jusqu'à
l'épuiser comme une salle aux folles a
traité m mais n'oublie pas qu'ici c'est
chez nous faut trois balles avec lui
faudrait qu'ils construisent un mélange
noir de la france j'te parle pas du
peuple français mes dirigeants de l'état
français
[Musique]
français voilà alors vous quand vous
avez vu ça ça vous a vraiment c'est pas
possible nous émeut tenue je crois que
c'est beau se situent nos maux de ses
passes et peut-être pas ma tasse de thé
mais héros au delà de ce que je peux
représenter c'est surtout les jeunes qui
m'interpelle où je suis un élu de la
nation très modeste élu de la nation
mais j'ai reçu sur mon mail c'est de
cette chanson et le clip vidéo qui m'a
particulièrement autres effectivement
mais ça compte pas cesser derrière 8500
personnes qui m'ont écrit quand je vais
dénoncer ces 250 élus toutes tendances
politiques confondues qui m'ont demandé
de passer de vars et donc beau jeu les
faits parce que effectivement je ne
reconnais pas du tout je pense que la
france est peut-être ça mais c'est
surtout autre chose quoi et on n'a pas
toujours à mettre le doigt sur de ces
agissements parce que sincèrement moi
j'ai voulu d'abord protéger nos mineurs
parce que c'est ce que tu es vidéo était
en roue libre durno sur sur sur internet
donc à disposition des grosses de 12 13
14 15 ans ce qui veut dire maman c'est
que le clip avait été interdit la
télévision et qui continuent à circuler
sur internet et donc à ce titre mon étal
de représentants du peuple j'ai voulu
dénoncer parce que parce qu'un élu se
doit aussi de protéger nos mineurs ne
peut pas laisser faire tout et des tout
dire donc que bon vous avez porté
plainte il faut le dire à titre
personnel ça vous coûte du blé ça vous a
coûté je te prennent entre 5000 et 7000
euros de frais quand ils parlent de
liberté d'expression quand ils vous
accusent de censure quand il parle de de
brassens quand il parle de renault quand
il parle de brel vous répondez quoi ben
écoutez moi je vous laisse le soin de
comparer ce type vidéo avait du brass et
c est tout le reste même ce qui est dit
à l'intérieur par rapport ce que disait
brassens mais moi je veux pas rentrer
dans ce court si vous voulez mon jeu je
défends la liberté d'expression parce
qu'on est dû est là pour défendre la
liberté d'expression moi je ne veux la
ceinture nulle part mais je crois qu'il
rémy a des limites quoi alors où elle
commet il s'arrête et effectivement moi
je suis pas là pour vous le dire en tout
état de cause le délit d' insulte c'est
pas moi qui l'inventé ça existe et de
saidal ses paroles on ne se fait
insulter du matin au soir alors qu'est
ce que ça peut amener c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser ça c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on atteint d'après cette chanson
après un clip vidéo après ces paroles on
attend quoi en attendant de la haine la
méchanceté qu'est-ce qu'on attend on
attend que des populations france on
attend du corporatisme moi je crois que
quand dans tous les discours comme moi
comme tant d'autres les élus y mettre le
mot tolérance qui ne qui n'est pour
augmente que le mot on est bien d'accord
mais quand on met le mot tolérance on ne
peut pas laisser passer ça parce que la
tolérance faut qu'elle soit réciproque
ou alors il ya eu un procès le 29 mai
donc aujourd'hui il ya eu le résultat du
délibéré vous avez été débouté j'ai été
jugée recevable parce qu'un député ne
doit pas porter plainte voilà alors
aujourd'hui que c'est pas c'est pas la
liberté d'expression qui a gagné
aujourd'hui c'est la liberté d'insulter
donc aujourd'hui effectivement on peut
considérer que ce ce type ne se soit
vous pouvez y aller un temps et même
faire plus c'est pas c'est pas le
problème
la justice a décidé qu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui on pouvait s svt moi je
pensais que c'était un délit et beynost
aujourd'hui on va prouver le contraire
mais alors après il faut savoir où ça va
mener tout ça quoi moi je suis pas sur
que derrière tout ça philosophiquement
on puisse avancer dans nos discours vous
êtes déçus par la justice française fait
un an je suis déçu je suis très en
colère je suis très en colère parce que
on entendu tout à l'heure un entraîneur
le second de secours bise qui disait que
la justice était illisible mais même
pour moi elle est illisible injustice
parce qu'au lieu de deux juges et le
faut on pense surtout comment ne pas
faire vous parler du fond voilà et vas-y
contourner comme brasse et comprend des
10 à 15 est jugée recevable se dire
qu'on évite de poser le problème en fait
exactement la question reste c'est une
astuce de procédure vous savez je les
dis à monsieur r lors du procès je ne
connais pas personnellement monsieur r
on aurait peut-être même dans la vie
peut être pu être amis cette enveloppe
d'autant plus laissez moi le dire quand
même que vous venez du même endroit dire
que vous vous êtes pas de paris j'ai pas
un bourgeois venus des cités vous avez
tv en hlm j'ai quitté l'école à l'âge de
13 ans ce nom un pur autodidacte mais
jamais casser trois pattes à un canard
c'est pas le problème on juger jeu
comment dire je
je me suis hissé de par le travail de
l'âge de 13 ans a maintenant et puis les
circonstances de la vie ont fait que
j'ai été vu sur un terrain d'une équipe
municipale et à ce que j'ai à ce que ce
n'est pas une réaction de bourgeois mais
pas du tout mais je sais ce que je dis
déjà j'ai vécu toute ma vie dans les hlm
donc c'est des gens que j'ai fréquenté
avec qui j'ai grandi avec qui j'ai une
affinité moi c'est sait lire tout sauf
ça alors je me dis presque on a presque
l'impression de vouloir se justifier
dans ses démarches mêlant moi j'étais
gosse j'ai des gosses qui ont vingt ans
et qui n'ont pas envie d'entendre de se
faire insulter toute la journée quoi
alors j'ai raison j'ai tort je sais pas
en tout état de cause du temps puisque
nous on est heureux mais on verra quoi
ça va mener sa part la question que je
pose c on fait ça pour quoi on va après
voilà que l'homme l'escaladé de la
violence va amener à quoi est-ce que
c'est des populations qui vont s'aimer
est-ce que des populations qui vont
essayer de se comprendre est ce que
c'est les populations qui vont
se comprennent le jeu je suis parce que
monsieur r non mais ce que je voulais
déjà c'est qu'il parle de population
c'est que il ya eu un grand débat par
exemple par rapport à son action c'est
que moi pour mon heat c'est à dire que
tu sois noir que tu sois arabe que tu
sois a
des origines d'asiatiques j'en parle pas
de population moi je quand je parle je
dis je commence mon morceau par dire
quand je parle de la france je parle pas
du peuple français mais des dirigeants
de l'état français donc déjà à partir de
ce moment là on parle pas de population
on parle juste d'une situation moi
est-ce que je vais l'expliquer c'est que
par exemple on m'accuse lui de 2
de pousser à la violence mais moi ce que
j'ai constaté parce que moi j'étais
véritablement sur les terres sur le
terrain pendant les émeutes je voyais
des jeunes français d'origine qui ont
des parents qui venaient du maghreb au
delà du maghreb ou de l'afrique noire ou
même qui ont des parents gaulois ou quoi
que ce soit qu'est ce qu'il faisait ils
sortaient leur carte d'identité
française ils ont jamais sorti mon
morceau mon album ils sortaient leurs
carnets de 10 tonnes d'identité
française et disaient nous on veut qu'on
veut être reconnu comme des français
pourquoi vous ne reconnaissez pas comme
des français à part entière c'est ça le
problème en fait le problème il est là
c'est qu'à chaque fois moi je n'ai marc
moi j'ai des filles par exemple j'ai
deux filles qui sont françaises qui sont
nés sur le sol français pour moi elles
sont françaises j'ai pas envie qu'on
leur demande à chaque fois on me demande
oui mais ils sont de quelle origine on
est français quelle que soit l'origine
qu'on peut avoir et dire qu'avant ce
moment commence à parler déjà d'origine
déjà il ya un problème je vais souvent
aux états unis et je vois souvent j'ai
beaucoup d'amis aux états unis qui sont
mêmes qui ont des origines sénégalaises
et tout ça et qui ont des origines
mexicaines ou aux cubains nous
dominicaine eh ben ils sont on lorsque
jamais tu entendras aux états unis dans
une chaîne de télé leur dire ouais mais
vous êtes américains ou colin powell par
exemple japon lui a dit oui mais vous
êtes américain d'origine jamaïcaine
c'est un américain donc à partir de là
quand vous parlez de population mois
déjà ça me vexe parce que c'est pas une
question de coopération c'est juste une
question que moi j'attaque l'état une
politique qui a été menée dans les
quartiers populaires une politique de
discrimination vers le président de la
république lui-même la politique de feu
de feu ne fait partie des leaders aussi
bob marley faisait aussi de la politique
en jamais c'est ça que vous oubliez ça
il ya beaucoup d'artistes qui ont mené
là le leurs chansons à de la politique y
en a des milliers tracy chapman que ce
syndrome harley ou peut se faire même
brassens ou renault beaucoup d'artistes
ont mené la politique après chacun fait
ce qu'il veut moi je suis rappeur gg je
me sens concernée par rapport à la
politique qui semaine parce que comme
dirait un chanteur un rappeur qu'on
appelle rockin squat il disait si tu ne
t'occupes pas de la politique c'est la
politique qui va s'occuper de toi donc
moi dans mes chansons je suis obligé de
m'occuper de la politique après tu as
des arts 19 vous la question des
rapports fait autant bien que je vous ai
pas coupé souvenez vous le faites autant
bien que vous allez avec besoin solo sur
tous les plateaux télé ou du moins
500 et 600 pris comme une centrale je ne
sais pas quel âge un peu ça c'est un ami
avant tout déjà la base à dire que moi
c'est un ami après moi je vois pas su si
les de la lcr puis ça du ps moi je vois
un être humain moi je suis un humaniste
est-ce que vous pensez que tout ça
finalement traduit un racisme anti blanc
devient il coûtait objectivement je ne
suis pas sûr et j'ai même pas envie de
l'entendre parce que ça me fait mal au
ventre qu'on est on essayait je dis pas
qu'on est con et tous bon en politique
loin de là parce que ça se saurait mais
on essaie quand même de rabbi ce côté un
peu c'est ces deux français qui
s'opposent actuellement on n'y arrivera
pas avec ça je le dis moi je suis à deux
doigts de baisser les bras on n'y
arrivera pas on vous jette de l'huile
sur le feu quand il se fait plus que
jeter de l'huile sur le feu monsieur
macheda est à deux doigts de même d'être
mineur d'une certaine population sait
que c'est musique s'adresse à des
mineurs cédé 12 15 ans qu'ils écoutent
ça et j'ai pas envie que de même sur mac
et là sur le leader deux de ces deux de
ses sites et je n'ai pas envie du tout
j'ai envie qu'ils attaquent qu'ils
apprennent notre sol quand vous parliez
de raconter d'histoires d'amour clip
excusez moi il ya ka le passé à
l'éducation nationale on fera des cours
d'histoire avec ça vous voulez voir ce
que vous voulez voir moi ce qui me
choque pas en quoi on parle d'
anti-blanc jouer vraiment la chose qui
me vraiment qui me fait le plus mal au
coeur parce que ça voudrait dire quoi
moi dans mon morceau jamais je parle de
race je parle pas de noirs deux villes
pas il aurait pu être noir ou arabe sa
politique c'est les mauvaises eh ben je
la combattrai de la même manière je
parle de francs d'ici là mais j'ai dit
vous savez pas qu'à des artistes qui ont
un esprit vous l'avez jamais dit ça
monsieur mac et là j'ai pensé je me lors
du procès vous avez toujours dit que
vous mettiez à côté de la politique que
ça vous regarde pas et que vous étiez un
artiste nous avons donc c'est un artiste
peut avoir une conscience politique et
thomas michel je suis très très très
heureux de vivre en france d'être
français
pour une raison simple c'est que il ya
très peu de pays au monde où ce débat
que vous avez tous les deux peuvent
avoir lieu en face de caméras et devant
des millions de gens dire que ce que je
trouve formidable dans la démocratie
c'est que vous vous affrontez vous
n'êtes pas d'accord
affronter le rap est une culture très
fort très profondes qui vient de la
marge qui vient de gens qui ont besoin
de s'exprimer qui ont besoin de se
révolter qui ont été pas qu'ils n'ont
pas été écoutés qui n'ont pas trouvé
d'identité qui trouve une identité très
forte dans leur musique dans leur texte
il bosse ibos y bossent dur et il
s'exprime avec violence parce que
d'abord la jeunesse c'est souvent
violents impertinent provocateur c'est
comme ça
et vous
vous représentez en partie l'institution
et vous exprimer et c'est formidable que
vous exprimiez c'est formidable que vous
affrontiez tous les deux ce qui est
formidable dans ce pays c'est que ça
puisse exister et que ça et ça doit
continuer à exister sans qu'ils s'en qui
viennent aux mains je veux dire que ce
qui est important c'est que lui
s'exprime avec toute la violence qui
veut sans que ça vienne aux mains que
lui s'exprime avec toute la
détermination même la violence qui veut
sans que ça vienne aux mains démocratie
c'est ça c'est ce qu'on est en train de
vivre maintenant et ça c'est magnifique
non mais vous êtes enfin vous avez tout
à fait raison parce que j'ai vécu sous
un dictateur pendant beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'années et
il n'y avait absolument pas de place
pour ça même pas un journal qui
parlerait quelque chose qui
critiqueraient le gouvernement du jour
au lendemain on peut en être sûr que ça
sera terminé pour le journal mais en
même temps je me suis dit que depuis que
je suis parti de l'indonésie il n'y a
pas un pays parfait
donc chacun où chaque pays chaque
personne fait toujours avec les moyens
du bord et donc comment on essaie de
cohabiter avec tout ça mais de toute
façon il est formidable la démocratie
est justement c'est important de pouvoir
être écouté
que vous parliez effectivement on reçoit
font uniquement sur le avec avec la
parole n'est pas mais il ya quand même
eu des affrontements en france et je
l'avais dénoncer justement avant ces
émeutes parce que je considérais que un
jour on en arrive aux romains je dis pas
comme monsieur mac elle est responsable
ça dieu préserve mais à force de
s'insulter à force de se cracher dessus
des uns les autres on ne peut arriver
qu'à ça je suis pas sûr qu'après des dvd
qu'on après des cd des dvd comme ça on
ne puissent se comprendre les uns les
autres je crois qu'il ya peut-être une
ou deux fois mais je crois qu'en en
muselant des gens qui veulent s'exprimer
avec autant de violence qu'ils le
veulent on arrivera à des situations
d'affrontement beaucoup plus forte je
crois que l'origine des affrontements et
des émeutes ne sont pas dans le travail
des rappeurs je crois que c'est beaucoup
plus profond monsieur je crois que ça
vient de beaucoup plus longtemps je
crois que le le le l'absence absolue de
conscience des gouvernants successifs
sur l'intégration sur l'immigration sur
le chômage sur la misère sur sur les
gens qui sont rejetés et sur
l'incompréhension que que ce pays a eu
deux contrairement effectivement aux
états unis cas beaucoup plus beaucoup de
défauts tout en déjouant jenifer yannick
aux états unis kpatcha particulier de
social tient pas de travail beaucoup tu
crèves dans la rue tu me crève dans la
rue moi mon frère et médecins du monde
il est allé dans une mission dans le
bronx pendant des mois il en a pleuré il
a dit ça c'est la première puissance du
monde il a vu des gens crever mais sans
rien bon donc je crois pas que au
contraire moi je crois que plus le rap
s'exprimera et plus vous vous direz ce
que vous pensez plus même y aura des
procès plus on se battra plus plus les
gens avec les mots dans la danse dans
l'univers et dans le respect de la
démocratie plus on évitera les émeutes
ce qui génère les émeutes c'est
l'incapacité qu'ont à s'exprimer c'est
l'incapacité qu'on a d'être écouté et
d'être reconnu là vous vous reconnaissez
tous les deux vous pouvez vous pouvez
vous affrontez vous n'êtes pas d'accord
sur les mots sur la forme mais ce qui
est fondamental c'est que ça ça puisse
exister parce que le jour où ça ça
n'existera plus et dans les endroits où
ça n'existe pas là on en vient aux mains
parce que à force de ne pas pouvoir
vivre sa propre parole on devient
violent ou alors à force de nier la
parole de l'autre on peut vouloir le
tuer parce qu'on peut pas supporter la
contradiction kinki mais dans notre
monde et il existe dans le monde des
gouvernants et des gouvernements qui
n'ont pas pu assumer ce genre de choses
et qui ont tué et c'est devenu des
dictatures alors c'est difficile la
démocratie l'exercice est compliqué j'ai
pas d'arguments n'a mené à tous et vous
venez de dire où je reviendrai
mais bien une fois qu'elle tourna court
on ne peut que se féliciter que ce soit
possible en france de se faire des
procès là-dessus d'en parler à la
télévision tu as faim sur une chaîne du
service public ce qui serait grave c'est
que vous réagissiez pas ce qui serait
grave c'est que lui parle pas si c'est
grave c'est que vous frappez l'un
l'autre maintenant à partir de là on
entend qu'on s'engueule
cher politiquement correct chez gaïa
mode j'aime j'aime les messieurs la
[Musique]
merci à tous les deux mr sida
j'accueille ilina nogueira
[Musique]
tiens donc vous avez été mannequin
chanteuse animatrice télé comédienne
écrivain
jamais rencontré un bon conseiller
fragmentation non non je réduis
rencontré véronique
quand il faisait qu est ce qu a fait l
mort et orienter la voilà alors ce soir
si la chanteuse que nous recevons le
disque s'appelle bang c'est un concept
album basée sur l'imagerie des des
gangsters américains commencer par
bonnie and clyde dans le disent vous
êtes dillinger girl la fille fantasmée
de john dillinger et l'autre moitié du
duo federico pellegrini le guitariste de
little rabbits lui il s'appelle baby
face nelson voilà alors c'est enregistré
à tucson arizona dans le mythique hôtel
qu'en grèce ou en 34 dellinger a été
arrêtée l'ennemi public numéro un en soi
c'est un road album disons que la
musique est née avant le concept et
c'est après qu'on a inventé l'histoire
mais finalement l'histoire est très
accessoire c'est vrai quoi j'ai
l'impression concernant par beaucoup
mais ne peut nier vaud oui mais on
oublie la musique en fait c'est surtout
de la musique et on accorde enfin si
elle fait quelque chose qui peut
intéresser les gens les journalistes et
animateurs de télé c'est pas mal oui bon
on a fait ça bourg pour rire et puis
c'était surtout des chansons et après
c'est devenu une espèce oui on peut le
comparer à un road movie et
alors ces produits par vous non vous
avez cassé votre petit cochon j'ai
revendu j'ai vendu mon master paraissait
productrice d'accord d'être entrées dans
vos sous et quand vous dites cet album a
été enregistré comme un malade ça veut
dire quoi parce qu'il a été très très
très vite fait c'est
tout ça est une espèce de collision donc
moi je travaille avec d'autres personnes
federico est censé me faire trois
chansons finale en fait 20 il fait
paroles et musiques
j'adore ce projet là donc on est parti
sur suit les chansons en juin on est
parti en octobre fin septembre
enregistré donc on est allé très vite on
n'a pas attendu en fait les maisons
disque c'est assez lent il faut il faut
expliquer il faut qu'il monte budget
c'est plus lent que la musique
finalement donc quand je dis c'est comme
un hold up c'est que je suis parti j'ai
pris j'ai pris mes économies ça m'a pas
coûté très cher mais allez le faire
parce qu'on avait envie que cette
musique existe vite et c'est ce qu'on a
fait donc voilà c'est dans ce sens là
que ça ressemble à un hold up mais je
n'ai pas vendu très cher
g
m
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
dernière fois que votre vie que vous
direz magnéto serge donc fait le comme
il faut
magnéto serge
monsieur
[Musique]
jack
[Rires]
m
il
[Musique]
risque
c'est ça
et ses yeux mais leur sort
ça va ça nous plaît ouais j'aime bien
ouais c'est très américain c'est vrai
nom tiré un on dirais pas qu'ils sont
tous formatés c'est bien ouais c'est
bien ah bin là pour le coup nous alors
c'est qu'on a reçu philippe katerine ici
il ya pas longtemps oui très bien passé
ça s'est bien passé mais on va finir
interview stimulus pour savoir ce qui
l'excité ce qui n'existait pas à faire
la même chose avec vous interview
stimulus i
les odeurs corporelles ça vous excite de
ça vous dégoûte ça m'excite un mec
intelligent ça vous excite tout ça vous
dégoûte 5 mixi les slips kangourous ça
vous excite tout ça vous dégoûte c'est
comment kangourous s'ils pour mettre la
ce
a dépensé suite dedans ça m'excite ça
vous excite les poignées d'amour ça vous
excite tout ça vous dessine la
télévision non plus complet rien ça vous
fait récemment d'or le sperme ça vous
excite tout ça vous dégoûte non plus
j'ai pas très sperme qua non et toi non
c'est pas le truc non non non c'est pas
un truc que je trouve très
et toi tu trouves non c'est pas le
sperme sympa c'est pas un produit je
trouve sans complexe et bactéries n'ont
été d'accord c'est pas non mais je pense
que tu aurais pu le faire en mer oui
mais voilà cette ne viserait qu'à
normand peut-être
bibliothèque
je suis pas très espère moi et toi
laurent moi j'essaie d'arrêter j'étais à
400 jours
alors que d'habitude
decatoire chaque site ça vous dégoûte
n'ont plus rien sinon bon mais pas des
goûts mais aussi l'homme que j'aime à ça
pour quoi
à entendre vos voisins du dessus faire
l'amour ça vous excite tout ça vous
dégoûte ma non plus neuf moi ça me plaît
moi si je suis tout seul c'est un peu ma
bière mais 60 ans et moi c'est moi mon
rêve d'ailleurs je le dis je cherche un
appartement qui donnerait
sur une boîte est changée non sur un
appartement d'exhibitionnisme si
quelqu'un a une adresse je suis preneur
c'est l'histoire drôle pour votre ca en
asie les histoires vraies ouais c'est au
ces il ya très longtemps
dans le music hall les gars partait en
tournée il n'y avait pas les trains
comme aujourd'hui et pas les tgv de
sanaa qui partait longtemps et un jour
il ya un 2-2 imprésario que je citerai
pas très très très grand imprésario qui
disent bon écoute on est à 300 bandes de
paris ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu
nos enfants on rentre
il parle sur la route et ils sont très
fatigués ils décident d'aller dormir et
il trouve à l'hôtel il n'y a plus qu'une
seule chambre de livres alors ils disent
au type bon écoutez on comprend la
chambre on est fatigué il se met au lit
tous les deux et asseoir exemple un
couple faire l'amour à côté impossible
de dormir
impossible ça dure une heure une heure
et quart il écrit et l'ema charest les
insulter tout ça et moi ça ils n'en
peuvent plus ils sont là ça se termine
ils peuvent plus dormir il décide de se
venger
non qu'ils décident de faire croire
qu'ils font l'amour les deux hommes pour
empêcher le coup de dormir et voilà qui
commence
bazilia le directeur de l'hôtel arrive
idiot pour veux pas de votre succès
c'est vrai mais sans
porter des sous vêtements masculins ça
vous excite tout ça ou des gouttes
je peux le faire mais pas forcément que
c'est un maxi ses douches entre filles
si vous excite tout ça bouge plus que
non nous attend si vous êtes chez vous
êtes très pas très branché fille
finalement non pas très branché d'auchan
fait
des films porno ça vous excite tout ça
vous dit sexy
petit plus la façon dont il recevait les
invités c'est un peu qu'il existera coup
révision après moins rapide la fourrure
ça vous excite tout ça vous dégoûte
j'aime bien le string en cuir
sur lui oui
un animateur télé tout en noir ça vous
excite ils savent où débouche pas du
tout je t'avais goûte un peu quand même
non je vais faire les chanteurs en son
pull rose à
des lieux publics c'est vous excite a
même bien su c'est un orteil j'aime bien
on l'a on a déjà fait ça mais que vous
ne l'avez déjà posé
ce que suspect est-ce que c'est tromper
l'eau s'est trompé de pied ouais les
mots crus au lycée vous excite tous à
vous dégoûter à ça dépend desquels mais
ça peut être comme des fleurs tout le
monde en parle ça vous excite tous à
votre goût tu as ça m'excite
c'est leur seul essai
et
de toi
alors parce que quand je regarde
l'émission j'ai quand même une question
est-ce que c'est toujours écrit la même
chose sur tout a confié comme ça une des
dernières j'en prends une ok ça c'est la
mienne après je vérifie d'accord ouais
ok je peux dire ce que j'ai vu que ça je
peux le dire c'est tout pas
[Rires]
ça dépend des invités oui c'est quoi la
tuer même bain donc j'avais pas le choix
un kart et ta soeur 1 vous devez chanter
une chanson de l'idiot à très bonne idée
ça déplaît pas que tu m'embrasses nan
mais faut saisir ta chance avant qu'elle
passe maintenant si tu cherches un truc
pour briser la glace
d'ananas banane
un celle des soeurs
l'abominable homme des neiges à la
salle des sports que ça là-bas mineurs
jeunes à la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
banane
[Musique]
banana
le junior
türkiye vous bon ben j'espère que la
prochaine fois qu'on se verra ça ira
bien j'espère que je serais pas obligé
de m'évader pour venir une de vos essais
qu'on l'appelle alors pour passer d une
quinzaine de mois bon bah alors insu à
l'art
[Musique]
j'accueille david foenkinos hommes
alors vous êtes écrivain vos livres sont
traduits dans plus de 10 pays et vous
publiez votre cinquième roman les coeurs
autonome chez grasset dans la collection
ceci n'est pas un fait divers dirigée
par jérôme béglé ou a déjà été publié un
enfant d'octobre l'histoire du petit
grégory par philippe besson alors les
coeurs autonome revisite son a nommé la
sphère florence rey et son destin vous a
fasciné apparemment oui c'est vrai que
je la nomme pas mais c'est clairement
inspiré de ce fait divers qui a lu en
1994 où il fasciné parce que je me
souviens son visage quand on a découvert
la une des journaux une jeune fille
presque innocente aux fins totalement
ailleurs et puis quand on apprend la
brutalité des faits c'était il ya eu
trois policiers assassinés un chauffeur
de taxi ça a vraiment marqué
effectivement beaucoup de gens alors
vous avez un procédé assez habile
d'ailleurs il ya un narrateur qui a
fréquenté florence rey puis son jumeau
pain et on rentre assez bien dans leur
intimité à travers ce narrateur alors ça
commence par par son enfance alors chez
elle son père est malade faut pas faire
de bruit pour pas réveiller les démons
du père qui est qui est fou cette
brutalité on a essayé de trouver un
petit peu comment comment une fille sans
histoire intelligente parce que c'était
etc c'était un couple qui avait fait des
études qui était intelligent comment
enfin comment une telle dérive avait pu
se produire en fait vous dites telle et
telle une ombre avec un sourire pour la
décrire il ya une phrase qui est pas mal
la puissance d'une histoire d'amour est
proportionnelle au vide qui la précède
et c'est vrai c'est vrai que quand elle
rencontre audry maupin en fait elle sort
d'une adolescence assez assez vide assez
creuse le point de départ c'est la
fascination pour cette pour ce garçon
qui est plus âgée qui est quelqu'un de
vraiment charismatique
qui a manifesté dans tout ça c'est celle
scellée l'année 94 c'était une
manifestation ces ip qui était vraiment
un leader une sorte de de rebelles en
fait voilà donc c'est cette image là là
beaucoup fasciné effectivement on peut
penser que toutes les histoires d'amour
l'importance qu'on peut qu'on peut tirer
en toute chose c'est le vide qui l'a
précédée alors lui son idée c'est de
en l'air cette société de merde
est elle effectivement elle elle tombe
amoureuse de lui et dès le départ le mot
d'ordre c'est ne pas le décevoir et là
on s'installe dans le mensonge en faible
effectivement le problème aussi c'est
quand on critique autant la société sait
comment la réintégrer après après ils
ont été forcément exclu de la société
est ce que la société et dans un rapport
amoureux alors un jour il lui ordonne de
quitter son boulot et puis pas à la fin
de la semaine ou à la fin du mois il
arrive il lui dit tu pars tout de suite
tu quittes ton job pourrait évidemment
c'est la fin de la vie sociale elle se
retrouve marginal il dans leur couple en
fait il est assez tyrannique avec elle
un lait à barreaux à lui et le supporte
mais lui il est très tyrannique oui mais
c'est une vraie description de la
passion amoureuse dans ce qu'il peut
avoir de plus avilissant dans cette
passion s'est pratiquement l'antichambre
de la de la haine il ya un rapport
vraiment de brutalité elle essaie de le
quitter à plusieurs moments mais c'est
une sorte de fascination
fatale qui va qui va aboutir finalement
à cette brutalité de trop à lui mais je
crois que c'est un rapport de toute
façon
équivalent je veux dire sont tous les
deux on sait pas on dit qu elle après
elle a suivi par amour mais à partir
moment où il a rencontré où se sont
rencontrés il ya sur deux ford de force
venimeuse entre eux 20 et quelque chose
assez malsain qui s'est dégagée de cette
union alors il quitte la société
organisée ils habitent dans une masure
et d'un seul coup l'idée jaillit ça
rejoint bonnie and clyde dilling et
regarder baby face nelson voler aux
riches qui devient un acte
contestataires donc il pense à un
braquage et elle va acheter un fusil à
pompe à à la samaritaine et quand elle
sort de là est très heureuse quoi c'est
peut-être le plus grand moment de sa vie
mais si une grande exaltation est ce que
tout ce qu'elle fait c'est pour lui
c'est avant tout c'est avant tout une
histoire amoureuse c'est l'histoire
d'une asphyxie amoureuse même alors elle
veut participer au braquage à ne
comprendraient pas de ne pas y
participer
et un soir il passe à l'acte alors il
arrive dans une pré fourrière en plus
c'est très bizarre non c'est une sorte
de scène presque à la pieds nickelés
c'est à dire ils sont là il voulait il
voulait il voulait prendre les menottes
des flics pour les menotter est parti en
courant mais cette fille qu'elle n'avait
pas de menottes elle a dit elle si il
avait eu des menottes rien de tout ce
qui s'est passé par la suite n'aurait
bien sûr parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
les attacher dont qui les arrose avec un
gaz lacrymogènes les flics se lève ils
ont très peur alors que les flics sont
dans un état où il ne pourrait pas
toutes façons les poursuivre mais ils
prennent peur en fait l'histoire c'est
ce à dire que oui il se la joue un peu
il se la joue autonome ils vont braquer
des filles dans une vraie fourrière est
en fait tout de suite ils prennent peur
il s'enfuit et là il manque dans un taxi
il oblige un taxi à ouvrir la porte et
il rentre dans ce taxi le début ça se
passe assez bien en taxi c'est un peu
que vous dites d'ailleurs comme du
covoiturage quoi oui non mais c'est vrai
que ce qui est fascinant dans les faits
divers sur tout ce qui rentre dans les
sports collectifs à suivre entre c'est
vraiment la succession de détails
infimes et ridicule est vraiment au
départ c'est un petit braquage et après
ils ont l'impression d'être suivi par
les filles et prennent en otage
effectivement un chauffeur de taxi
malheureusement ils tombent sur la
pierre situation puisque c'est un
chauffeur de taxi guinéen est en fait
ils disent aux chauffeurs de nous tes
papiers comme ça si tu nous dénonçons tu
retrouveras voilà huit panique
totalement il s'était papier comment je
vais faire pour les retrouver lui
dédiant il est quand même inquiet il a
quand même le flingue vraiment sur la
tempe je vais taxi veut pas me donner
ses papiers parce qu'il se dit après je
ne récupérerai pas il a une famille là
des enfants dont qui se dit ça va être
très compliqué donc il veut pas donner
des papiers en fait c'est terrible cette
histoire parce que c'est c'était
tragique quoi c'est à dire que ça tient
à rien ça tient au fait que ce chauffeur
de taxi ne veut pas donner ses papiers à
ces deux adolescents qu'ils ont braqué
et il précipite sa voiture son taxi
contre une voiture de police voilà c'est
une section vraiment de d'absurdité
dramatique alors après il ya la grande
part mystérieuse c'était au moment où
effectivement cette voiture fonce sur la
sur la sueur sur la voiture de policiers
lui
le jeune homme sort brutalement et
arroser les fics est vraiment avec une
brutalité inouïe et après si c'est cette
partie de l'histoire aussi cassé
fascinante crl qu'est ce qu'elle fait à
ce moment là et en fait elle a commencé
à tirer elle a commencé à agir avec lui
et c'est le début d'une course poursuite
et d'un rodéo dont on se souvient tous à
paris entre nation et vincennes alors
lui effectivement ils tirent sur les
flics qui commence à arroser tout le
monde l on dit qu'elle a tué personne
mais sur le moment oui on a pensé
qu'elle avait tué parce que elle a tiré
quand même alors est-ce que c'était pour
protéger est-ce que c'était pour
participer effectivement c'est un fait
divers avec énormément de complicité
dans des nuitées ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ce que vous racontez vous
dites au moment où il est mort elle
pousser des ailes sur le ciel c'est ça
c'est beau cette histoire quand on va
sur internet on t'a florence rey il ya
des sites entiers à son à son à son
effigie ou des tee-shirts à son effigie
il ya eu beaucoup de livres beaucoup de
patrick desseaux enfin sonné g pour
florence rey effectivement elle fascine
énormément et en même temps ce qui
fascine c'est cette histoire d'amour
cette dernière cène effectivement lui
est abattu et elle se jette sur lui elle
embrasse avant d'être rattrapé par les
policiers hélas elle rentre dans un
mutisme dont elle n'est jamais sortie
est d'ailleurs les grands flics qui ont
interrogés disent on a jamais vu un
mutisme pareil bunkérise en elle-même
quoi après plus tard repro cl un bien
que chargé parce qu'elle a joué la
passion amoureuse effectivement c'est la
métamorphose d'une jeune femme en fait
devient complice d'un meurtrier par
amour quoi exactement très belle
exactement si c'est un fait divers qui
cristallise l'époque en même temps c'est
complètement moi j'avais j'avais 20 ans
j'en avais on avait le même âge et
participer aux mêmes même manifestation
effectivement c'est cette époque 1994
c'est balladur ccip c'est pasqua qui
voulait rétablir la peine de mort on a
aussi beaucoup parlé de la violence du
cinéma cette époque c'était tueur mur
voilà on a on atterrit jeunes a aussi
affirmé effectivement et d'ailleurs on
sait pas trop si l'histoire ce fait
divers est un peu instrumentalisé
s'étaler on sait pas s'il est si
certaines personnes n'ont pas mis les
affichettes de tueurs nés dans leur
squat alors qu'ils étaient signifie il y
avait il y avait des affiches de fritz
lang en fait
parce qu' une telle violence après on
peut faire passer toutes les toutes les
lois les plus sécuritaires vous avez une
belle phrase je ne sais pas l'écrivain
qui s'empare du fait divers mais le fait
divers qui s'empare d'avec les bas c'est
un peu ce que j'étais arrivé oui je
crois vraiment moi j'ai été marqué
depuis très longtemps par cette histoire
non
j
je nomme je suis racheté
quel frédéric recrosio
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai pas
bonjour je suis animateur radio
chroniqueur au matin et vous êtes ici
pour votre one man show qui s'appelle
écoute bien dit laurence la peña les
idées vachement bien sans doute rêvé
grandir et coincer des malheureuses
c'est pas mal trop court
c'est au trévise du mardi au samedi à
21h30 alors le plus sainte croix comme
on vous connaît pas c'est de regarder à
quoi ça ressemble j'ai regardé votre
caméra c'est le cas le rouge vert et
rouge -1 vous it magnéto serge
mais on veut juste rencontré quelqu'un
pour de bon parce qu'en fait il suffit
d'une fille trouviez les filles
ça c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai mais je me suis dit ça
sonne bien je laisse
non mais non parce que tout ce qu'on
veut nous les garçons mais c'est comme
pour vous on veut juste tombé amoureux
pour de bon bah oui sauf que voilà il ya
peu de gens qui font la faire bah oui
c'est vrai moi je sais pas vous mais
pour moi enfin il ya des trucs chez les
filles qui sont éliminatoires
le pendentif avec le dauphin
et c'est pas être misogynes que dire ça
non parce que le mauvais goût comme tout
le reste d'ailleurs est répartie de
manière tout à fait équitable entre les
deux sexes
trouve simplement que j'en fréquente cas
voilà révérend n'y ait pas assez les
malheureuses
sept autres élise
sellas la biographie sexuelle d'un un
trentenaire depuis sa plus tendre
enfance quoi hein vous raconter comment
l'homme devient un prédateur sexuel web
en langue comme tout le monde n'est ce
pas c'est un peu une histoire des
appétits c'est vrai que comme moi
j'étais petit j'ai rêvé d' aventure des
bus devrait avec la jungle des tigres et
des machins et après quand j'ai 25 ans
je me suis rendu compte qu'ils avaient
des aventures un peu moins dans des
cages d'escaliers des majorettes et
c'est difficile de se relever de ça moi
qui voulais tintin et je me suis rendue
compte qu'elle et mick jagger aussi
quitté la demande donc à vous raconter
votre premier coït en cours de
gymnastique ça s'est passé comment nous
on a six cordes et je monte je trouvais
ça c'est pas tant parce et acrobatique
bravo à tous les trucs qu'on fait
habituellement les roulades jeter de
balle tous ces trucs en nuire ont
regardé les cordes et compte recruter
juste chouette et en mon temps je
pensais pas que j'allais être candidat
traversé par une certaine volupté qui
fait que je suis jamais arrivé au sommet
à partir de là tout a changé
à préserver de toute suffisance en mai
mois des années en plus on 19 rien que
dalle ouais ouais mais alors par contre
alors là je me suis endetté sur ma vie
future enfin exemptera pas prêt et bien
sûr le cunnilingus vous montrer un
rubik's cube pressé le symbole pour voir
comment on fait accueillir un gus à un
rubik's cube rouge symbole de la
complexité du sexe féminin et sauf que
le rubik's cube tu perds tu achètes un
ancien même ouais
tandis que là les filles ya tellement de
déclinaisons ben voilà c'est un espèce
de rubik's cube comme ça chaque fois
nouveau ce qui démontre un peu le côté
aléatoire de nos pratiques baroque moins
bas que autour de sa merci
j'ai marqué sa vie
frédéric brochot
au bateau blind test
je rappelle monsieur
la partie bois il est pas venue du saint
palais noël est tranquille et bah ouais
c'est normal mais qu est député ump il
fait son boulot where cause il l'a fait
aussi voilà en bien ou en mal et pour
mettre les dix j'appelle les putafranges
alors les putafranges jouer à se trouver
au paris paris à la soirée nano micro
mono le dernier vendredi de chaque mois
voilà ça sympa merci les filles
alors vous connaissez le principe c'est
l'équipe de michel boujenah contre
l'équipe de anggun à vous les
putafranges
enfants de staline et c'est bien parce
que ses équipes dans gone en continu
[Musique]
6 ça fait deux points pour l'équipe
d'angondjé commence très fort
attention les nacres ils répondent avant
que la chanson le commande c'est toute
l'histoire c'est assez de réponses sur
l'intro on y va les filles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo laurent dur des ip françaises avec
on peut pas changer de côté
elle est pas du château
ce jour là
chevallier
tiens là malheureusement si on sait pas
adriano celentano ça oui je m'en
souviens maintenant et voilà on continue
oui j'avais peur
originale la tombée du ciel
tha
non
tombée de la nuit
on continue
l'exploit c'est dans l'exploit c'est
d'avoir zéro point vous avez rire
et je te reprendre l'année celle là me
reprendre quoi bah je sais pas mais j'ai
même failli aller vers ces la tuque
notre réel font-elles tel ou tel fait
jean pas qu'elle
s'est battue va la trouver à vous les
filles
[Musique]
jours
moi je suis nul mais si même l'écrivain
ici mais on est foutu et
est tombé sur une équipe de folie la wec
parce qu'ils trouvent tous et à tour de
rôle coincé par un qui trouvent là
donnez moi le titre avant
l'annoncé de zéro quand même michel à
7,0 je m'en fous
bâle
j'ai frappé un 8-0 je vais me lever
j'aime le frapper y a pas le droit de
répondre même si tu sais tu le laisses
comme ça on marque un point
et c'est un peu de courtoisie en moyenne
inférieur technique
la venue chez moi
la wii est génial laurent c'est que cet
après-midi jouvert le blind je me dis
avalon bryan ferry personne va trouver
tu vois moi même je connais à peine y
trouve
qu'est ce que c'est
à
[Applaudissements]
quelle issue du para équipe 0 point pour
vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est dommage que le député le japala
trouver réponse 3 et 10 points pour vous
un goon
là
avec eux les yeux
o o
oh
on
attend on joue maintenant
bisous donc on est prêt mini banco
l'épitaphe
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas
ouais
non
non ça arrange thierry salvi paul du lou
reed parry trop vite et on faisait
quelqu'un finale
pour moi attention le bon coup
[Applaudissements]
les regards le retour de michel boujenah
compliqué
m
[Musique]
gold français
si ça peut pencher sur
merci
david lee a bridge
[Musique]
l'emploi
ouais
murray
oasis
c'est parti libéral
oh
je suis
oui ce serait pas mal non ré écoute pas
soir c'est vachement bien c'est le
disque et ou moins ce que ti 30 verre
avec une grosse bête non
non mais gabon co les filles nadia
[Musique]
ah oui
il était temps
on aurait dit
oui oui
oui
m
zz top non
téléphoniques non
c'est très connu
hermann hesse hermann hesse c'est un
indice herman
stp noah coin
[Musique]
c'est paul wolff ouais le loup des
steppes mme hermann hesse bravo c'était
dur ça c'était pas évident ans et
maintenant l'ultra banco celui ou celle
qui va trouver le titre en signera pour
l'année proche
n'exagérons rien quand même
bon
c'est quoi
les
initiales
big six minutes chaudes
m
[Musique]
et
mais voilà messieurs c'était l'avant
dernier tout le monde en parle
jean
bart à
rangoun l'album s'appelle
en première partie du fleuve chaque tour
de johnny lee olivier de kersauson la
bretagne où les moeurs c'est au cherche
midi
michel boujenah
le 3 juillet au zénith de paris et le
web même champ les nouveaux magnifiques
en tournée
je n'ai ni 3d s'en alla bien blanches
sur l'estivé
froid jmj de paris en tournée à partir
du 23 septembre et a besoin du 26
décembre à l'olympia véronique jannot
mélanie maudran et secret du volcan avec
corinne touzet marianne falcone en août
france 2 et puis le bouquin les secrets
du volcan donne n'arrive qu'à toi chez
michel lafon sortie le 13 juillet
trouver le chemin des vernis janot chez
michel lafon musher l'album hicham el
politiquement incorrect et un autre
album black album voilà daniel mach donc
votre copain helena noguerra l'album
s'appelle wang jing jerger et des
vitesses jeunes du festival la route du
rock le 12 août à saint-malo avant
l'encours by david funky noces les
cartes au no mercy si chez grasset
frédéric recrosio rêver grandir et
coincer des malheureuses autres
du mardi au samedi à 21h30 et
putafranges rencontre ou vegan et
vendredis de chaque mois au bail paris
voilà ils sont retenus foot pour la
liberté de la presse au trophy le
reporter sans frontières voilà
qu'est ce qui n'est plus
c'était tout le monde en parle rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour le
dernière
[Musique]
hu
les mauvaises
[Musique]
et
oh
m
oui
[Musique]
m
oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu